Noël ma mère, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors, je m'appelle Noël ma mère. Mon
prénom Noël est lié à ma naissance le 25
décembre 1948.
J'ai été journaliste pendant longtemps,
pendant plus de 25 ans. Puis ensuite
j'ai me suis engagé dans la vie
politique
et j'ai donc été membre du parti
écologiste, parti vert. Donc j'ai été le
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
2002. J'ai été maire de Beigle, une
ville de la banlieu bordelaise pendant
28 ans et j'ai été député à l'Assemblée
nationale, député écologiste euh pendant
20 ans, de 1997 à 2017, date à laquelle
j'ai laissé ma place de maire.
Considérant que 28 ans c'était beaucoup
et je n'ai pas été candidat aux
élections législatives considérant que 4
mandats, 20 ans de de parlement, c'était
suffisant. Surtout quand on appartient à
une formation politique qui réclame le
la vitalité démocratique et le
renouvellement. Voilà. J'ai j'étais donc
depuis cette époque, je suis plutôt dans
la transmission et j'ai renoué, on va
dire, avec ce qui est mon seul métier,
le journalisme mais de loin puisque je
n'ai plus je n'ai plus de carte de
journaliste. Mon numéro de carte était
et que je réponds à la sollicitation de
mes amis écologistes lorsqu'ils me le
demandent sans m'imposer parce que j'ai
trop vu de vieux qui voulaient s'imposer
lorsque j'étais en fonction.
Et quand j'ai des sollicitations pour
des reportages ou [grognement] des
documentaires, je je n'hésite pas à y
répondre. Je je d'ailleurs pour ce qui
concerne les documentaires, je n'attends
pas qu'on vienne me chercher. Je propose
des idées de documentaires qui peuvent
être réalisés. Certains d'entre eux
d'ailleurs ont été diffusés paré France
5 ou ou France 2 avec notamment un
réalisateur qui s'appelle Philippe
Borel. On on a décidé de vous faire
venir aujourd'hui euh en grande partie
pour votre passif dans le journalisme,
votre grande expérience dans le
journalisme. On va on va discuter un
petit peu de votre regard sur la presse.
Comment ça se passait déjà à votre
époque ? Quel âge vous avez ?
Bien, comme je suis né le 25 décembre
1948, si vous êtes bon en calcul, vous
allez considérer que j'aurai 72 ans le
25 décembre 2020. Donc Noël est encore
bien vert.
On vous a fait venir pour tout ça euh
pour aussi faire de la transmission,
peut-être combler le fossé
intergénérationnel,
essayer de mettre les choses à plat.
Pourquoi il y a tellement de défiance
face à la presse ? Est-ce que c'est vos
années qui ont mis les graines de cette
défiance ?
On va on va essayer d'explorer ce type
de question. On va essayer de se tarder
aussi sur la crise du Covid, peut-être
la crise écologique aussi euh euh les
institutions, le monde politique et et
toutes ces ces ces petites choses qui ne
sont en fait que l'écume des choses.
Oui, enfin c'est pas l'écume des choses.
Tout ce dont vous venez de parler, ce
sont les symptômes d'une société malade.
Disons que si on devait résumer
l'entretien que nous allons avoir
pendant un certain nombre de quarts
d'heures, ce serait de se demander
pourquoi le futur a laissé la place à
l'incertain. Et quand on est dans le
brouillard de l'incertitude,
ça ça touche toutes les catégories de la
société. Comme diraient mes confrères
journalistes, ça touche la société dans
tous les compartiments du jeu. Ça ne
touche pas que les les plus vulnérables,
ça touche aussi ceux qui sont considérés
comme parce qu'on ne peut pas construire
un projet, un récit sur de
l'incertitude. Et c'est précisément ce à
quoi nous sommes confrontés. Donc quand
vous évoquez la situation d'aujourd'hui,
c'est pas simplement une situation
sanitaire, c'est l'expression
de [grognement]
ce que certains que vous avez d'ailleurs
reçu ici comme Pablo Servigne appelle
les signaux, les perturbations qui
peuvent conduire à l'effondrement d'un
monde. Alors, je ne suis pas dans la
dans la dans la lignée de ceux qui
pensent que nous sommes en train
d'assister à la fin du monde. Ça c'est
une forme,
c'est une version apocalyptique et
millénariste qui ne peut que conduire à
comment dire au fait que l'on se lance
on refuse toute action politique pour
changer le monde puisqu'on est tellement
vitrifié et figé par cette idée
[grognement] de de l'apocalypse. Ce que
propose d'ailleurs Pablo Servite, c'est
pas du tout ça. C'est l'idée de la fin
d'un monde. C'estàd qu'on est en train
de voir à travers cette métaphore géante
et planétaire qui est la COVID-19,
on est en train de constater la
fragilité et la vulnérabilité du modèle
de société que qui est aujourd'hui
dominant, ce qu'on appelle le
capitalisme ou le néolibéralisme. ce que
certains auteurs comme Serge Audier dans
son dernier livre qui s'appelle la cité
écologique appelle le capitalo
l'anthropo capitalocè puisque les hommes
estiment que c'est le capitalisme qui
est la cause de tous nos mots sur quoi
ils se trompent parce que le
productivisme soviétique a apporté les
mêmes les les les mêmes horreurs à la
fois en terme de liberté en terme humain
et en terme écologique et et et et
anthropocène c'est sans doute une très
bonne une une très bonne qualification,
sauf que tout le monde n'a pas la même
responsabilité dans la situation
écologique dans laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui.
On va parler de votre maronnier plus
tard. Euh la presse
alors la presse
Attendez attendez attendez attendez
qu'est-ce qui explique cette défiance du
peuple
face à la [raclement de gorge] presse ?
Qu'est-ce qui a créé [grognement]
ce climat délétaire ? C'est parce que
les journalistes ne font plus
correctement leur travail. C'est parce
qu'il y a plus 10 % des journalistes qui
travaillent correctement. C'est parce
que 90 % des journalistes ont été
sélectionnés pour prolonger le rondrond
quotidien. C'est parce que tout
simplement les journalistes sont
déconnectés. Qu'est-ce qui a amené la
presse à être détestée autant qu'un
croque mort ? Alors, dans votre
question, il y a déjà plusieurs éléments
de réponse.
Il se trouve que comme j'étais
journaliste et que j'essayais d'avoir un
regard détaché sur mon métier,
j'ai essayé de de l'analyser tout en
étant dedans euh et dehors. Et en 1988,
j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelait La
dictature de l'odimat.
C'était sans doute prémonitoire. Mais si
je l'ai écrit en 88 aux éditions la
découverte, c'est parce que il y avait
déjà les signes de cette course à
l'audience. Donc je pense que ce sont
des raisons principalement économiques
finalement qui ont conduit à la
situation dans laquelle se trouve
aujourd'hui euh la presse. Euh qu'est-ce
que vous entendez ? Qu'est-ce que vous
entendez parler ?
Et bien parce qu'il fallait qu'elle soit
rentable et moi je me souviens très
bien.
La merde ça rapporte. C'est ça.
Exactement. Exactement. Et c'est ça qui
a complètement pourri le euh le le monde
de l'audiovisuel en particulier. Alors,
quand on ajoute à ça la naissance des
télévisions euh d'information en continu
et euh euh la privatisation euh de
grandes chaînes publiques, l'avènement
des réseaux sociaux, vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
notamment les télévisions d'information
en continu, elles sont dans une
concurrence obsène et effrainée avec les
réseaux sociaux au point que,
comme le dirait Trump, la vérité n'est
plus qu'une opinion comme une autre. Et
cette course folle, elle est un
véritable poison. Moi, j'ai souvent
expliqué que au fond notre la presse
d'une manière générale, mais il faut pas
mettre toute la presse dans ce même
panier parce que ce n'est pas vrai. Mais
disons que le mainstream, il est victime
de trois poisons qui d'ailleurs sont se
sont répandus dans l'ensemble de la
société. C'est la dictature de
l'instant, la tyrannie de l'émotion et
la simplification.
Vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui vous
quand vous regardez certaines émissions
absolument effroyables, je pense
notamment à des émissions comme celle de
C News
l'émission de Pascal pro par exemple ou
le journal de France 2
ou le journal de France 2. Oui. Oui. Qui
n'est pas qui ne va pas aussi loin que
le l'heure des pros. Mais oui, en effet,
on vit l'image, le la télévision d'une
manière générale. Alors, disons, on va
faire des classification. La télé
d'information continue, elle véhicule
l'image d'un monde qui ne peut pas se
passer d'image. C'est un petit peu la
technique du sapeur camomember. Il y a
un trou, il faut le remplir. Donc c'est
ainsi que vous pouvez voir émerger des
faits divers totalement banales qui
n'ont aucun sens journalistique
qui ne qui ne suscitent pas une
explication pour éclairer l'opinion
puisque le rôle du journalisme c'est
d'essayer d'éclairer l'opinion afin
qu'elle se fasse une idée sur
influencer. Je pose cette question
je vous pose cette question. On va
rebondir sur les élections américaines.
Mais j'ai pas terminé mon explication
sur le on a on a du temps.
D'accord.
Je vous coupe. Les élections
américaines, les journalistes sont
censés être éclairés. Je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous. Mais
comment se fait que les résultats ne
soient pas annoncés officiellement et
que déjà les médias annoncent
Ah oui ? Non mais là vous parlez des
États-Unis, c'est c'est tout à fait
différent. C'est pas
Mais non mais le le le courant français
de la presse fait la même chose. On
boîte le pas tout de suite derrière. Non
mais ça fait longtemps.
Alors même si Biden a déjà gagné ou pas,
oui,
ils ont les résultats de où c'est ça
éclairé, c'est-à-dire donner une
tendance ou influencer l'opinion
publique.
Non, mais ça c'est lié à la en effet, on
peut très bien dire aujourd'hui, mais
alors là, vous vous classistes
qui euh Pourquoi on se classe devant les
complotistes ?
Bah parce que parce que c'est une
tradition aux États-Unis. D'abord,
d'abord, on ne dit pas qu'il est élu, il
est le Président Intellect. Euh
d'ailleurs, les télévisions sont
appelées après avoir consulté l'agence
IP qui est une coopérative de plusieurs
agences qui fixe le qui fixe d'une
certaine manière euh la règle qui est
une règle non écrite. Lorsque AP
considère queon peut que it's time to
call pour appeler, alors les
télévisions, c'est la tradition
annoncent cette élection mais il
l'annonce sur des bases solides. Et
pourquoi il n'y a pas de d'annonce ? On
attend pas l'annonce officielle,
pourquoi il y a pas l'annonce officielle
d'un ministère de l'intérieur ? Parce
que les États-Unis sont un gouvernement,
sont une République fédérale
et que ça dépend des États que de toute
façon le dépouillement ne se fait pas à
la même au même moment ou en tout cas
pas à la même vitesse qui ne se fait pas
au même moment parce qu'il y a quatre
fuséaux horaires. Donc on ne peut pas
être dans la même logique qu'en France.
Mais ce système fonctionne depuis le 19e
siècle et jusqu'à maintenant, il ne me
semble pas qu'il y ait eu des erreurs si
grave que ça remettait en cause ce
qu'annonçait ce qu'a annoncé euh les
télévisions à la suite de l'agence IP.
Pour répondre à votre question, c'est
vrai que les sondeurs, les sondages et
les sondeurs ont pris de plus en plus
d'importance dans la vie politique
puisqu'ils sont
dans la vie des journalistes.
Oui, dans la vie des journalistes sans
doute. Oui, puisque vous avez
aujourd'hui, mais ça c'est une
perversion des des sondages puisqu'on
fait un sondage pour à n'importe quelle
occasion. Vous aviez bien vu comment par
exemple sous la période sarkoziste, on a
pratiqué ce que nous appelions certains
d'entre nous le populisme pénal. À
chaque fait d'hivers important, on
suscitait une loi. Il y a rien de pire.
Ça c'est c'est ce que j'appelle la
dictature de l'émotion. Et on ne
construit pas l'état de droit et on ne
garantit pas nos libertés en répondant
uniquement à l'émotion. La force de la
loi, c'est justement d'être délibéré,
d'être débattu à froid. Et c'est vrai
que à chaque fois vous aviez des télés,
notamment les télés d'information
continue qui lançaient des sondages. Ces
sondages, ils sont un petit peu comme
Facebook. Je n'y vais pas moi, je n'y
suis, j'ai jamais fréquenté les réseaux
sociaux, ni Facebook, ni Twitter.
Un peu par principe philosophique
influencé par celui qui était mon
professeur avec qui j'ai milité qui
s'appelle Jacquelul.
[grognement]
Mais euh en effet, vous voyez bien que
Facebook, on se sont des petites tribus,
hein. C'est comme des des espèces de de
bandouan comme l'été en Afrique du Sud
où chacun se conforte. Bien. Oui, quand
vous faites des sondages après des des
faits divers, la question qui est posée,
c'est des questions qui suscitent des
réponses qui vont dans le sens de ce que
souhaite les journalistes et même
quelquefois le pouvoir. Donc bien
souvent, les journalistes se
transforment en relais d'un pouvoir qui
de plus en plus prétend représenter le
peuple en en choissant les méthodes du
populisme parce que ça c'est du
populisme.
C'est vous qui virez complotiste.
Non, je ne vire pas complice. Je fais un
constat.
pas, je vous accuse pas de complotisme
mais je pense que ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis ne peut pas être remis en
cause sauf par monsieur Molsonaro ou
madame Le Pen.
Ce qui est exactement le cas
aujourd'hui, je vous signale
très bien. Est-ce que le fait que la
population soit en défiance totale face
à la presse, ça va faire changer la
presse ou la presse va continuer son
rondron quotidien ? Mais la population,
elle n'est pas simplement c'est ça le
problème, c'est que la population, elle
n'est pas simplement en défiance
vis-à-vis de la presse, elle est en
défiance vis-à-vis des politiques aussi.
Et elle met dans le même sac et les
politiques. C'est ce que dans une
version de la simplification, on
appellerait les élites contre le peuple.
Bon euh on a on a notamment qualifié le
mouvement des gilets jaunes d'un
mouvement du peuple contre les élite. Il
y avait de ça dans le mouvement des
gilets jaunes. Mais ce qui ont remis en
cause et c'est ça qui est le plus
important à mon point de vue et on en a
pas encore tiré les conséquences, c'est
que les gilets jaunes, ils ont
interpellé pour la première fois depuis
longtemps la représentation politique et
la représentation des journalistes. Et
et en effet, ils ont montré qu'il y a
une sorte de lien aujourd'hui entre le
monde politique et le monde médiatique
qui fonctionne finalement d'une manière
un petit peu en circuit fermé, qui
fonctionne un petit peu hors sol. dans
le bouquin que j'avais écrit qui
s'appelait la dictature de l'udimat,
j'avais dit c'est le les médias parlent
au médiia et au bout d'un moment vous
avez toute une partie de la France qui
ne se sent pas concernée par la manière
dont on aborde le monde ou dans cette
catégorie aborde le monde. Bah ils se
sentent ils deviennent de plus en plus
invisibles et ils nourrissent ce qui est
le carburant du populisme, le
ressentiment. C'est d'ailleurs là-dessus
que par exemple Trump a a prospéré et
c'est vrai que chez dans le journalisme,
il y a en effet cette tendance depuis
longtemps à une forme d'embourgeoisement
mais il faut pas non plus mettre tous
les journalistes dans le même panier. %
parce que la plupart c'est 2 % la
plupart des journalistes en France c'est
pardonnez-moi les
c'est les crèves la dalle mais tout à
fait je je suis je peux en témoigner
puisque je l'ai je l'ai j'ai j'étais
journaliste et puis après j'étais
interrogé par les journalistes à la
salle des quatre colonnes par exemple à
l'Assemblée nationale dont je faisais
partie dont j'étais un bon client bien
je voyais des jeunes journalistes qui
étaient des portes micro en fait on leur
disait il faut que tu fasses 30 secondes
de ma mère 40 secondes de truc une
minute d'intel mais c'est pas ça le
métier. Je me disais les malheureux, on
les a transformé en soutier de
l'information sont des OS de
l'information des ce qu'on appelait et
et c'est vrai que chez les qui qui qui
pratiquent le métier selon des exigences
finalement économiques parce qu'on leur
dit si tu fais pas ça, il y en a 10
derrière toi qui accepteront de le
faire. Donc c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
dans le le monde journalistique
aujourd'hui, c'est un monde de classe.
Il y a les aristocrates de
l'information, puis après
après il y a après il y a les petits
bourgeois et puis après il y a ceux qui
remplissent la machine.
Bon parlons parlons de votre
et qui eux sont et qui eux sont
complètement précarisés.
Parlons un peu de votre grande
expérience. Vous avez présenté un
journal un jour, quelque chose qui
ressemblait. Ah oui oui oui oui. J'ai
même fait plus que ça. Oui oui, j'ai
j'ai
à la demande de Louis Berriot, il sil
faut rendre à César ce qui lui
appartient même si Louis est aujourd'hui
décédé. Il était rédacteur en chef de la
rédaction d'antenne 2. Donc Jean-Pierre
Elcabche était le directeur de
l'information et il m'a fait venir de
Bordeaux pour créer avec lui, je parle
de Louis Berriot, la première émission
généraliste traitant de question
d'environnement et de défense du
consommateur qui s'appelait C'est la
vie.
Donc, j'ai présenté et dirigé cette
émission pendant 5 ans de 1977 à 1981,
ce qui est à peu près la préhistoire
pour ceux qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui.
Et ensuite, pendant cinq autres années,
j'ai présenté le journal de 13h qui
s'appelait antenne de midi. Et après,
pendant cinq autres adé
et conduit une émission sur les droits
de l'homme qui s'appelait Résistance où
mon métier consistait à aller voir les
victimes plutôt que les bourreaux. un
peu partout dans le monde.
Votre regard sur les fake news. Première
question, est-ce que vous avez été
obligé d'annoncer au journal des fake
news qui se sont révélé et des fake news
par la suite ?
Non non, je n'ai pas été je n'ai pas été
euh je n'ai pas été confronté à cette
cette situation.
Si je vous demande de vous mettre dans
la peau par exemple,
j'ai vécu si j'ai vécu un moment euh que
que j'ai d'ailleurs expliqué plus tard,
qui m'a valu un procès pendant 10 ans
qui a été réglé d'ailleurs par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme. C'est
la catastrophe, c'est Ternoby.
En effet, je présentais le journal de
13h au moment de Ternobyl mais on était
deux présentateurs et qui se qui
alternent semaine après semaine. Et et
donc c'est vrai que j'ai vu comment le
lobby nucléaire
était en train de nous menter. Ils
avaient délégué le premier d'entre eux
qui était le patron du SCPRI qui
s'appelait le service central de
protection des rayons ionison qui était
l'équivalent de de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui s'appelait le professeur
Pèlerin et qui venait nous expliquer
sans le dire hein formellement que
finalement il y avait rien à craindre en
France et que le nuage de Ternobyl
n'avait pas franchi nos frontières. Il
ne l'a pas dit textuellement.
Euh mais nous recevions des images, les
grandes chaînes sont abonnées à une
bourse d'images qui s'appelle les EVN
qui sont envoyés le matin et le soir.
Donc quand vous regardez aujourd'hui le
journal de TF1 ou le journal de France 2
ou tous les autres journaux, vous voyez
souvent pour des événements où les
reporters, les envoyés spéciaux de ces
chaînes n'étaient pas présents, voyez
souvent les mêmes images. Ce sont des
images envoyées par cette bourse
d'échange. Et la bourse d'échange nous a
envoyaé des images de Suède et
d'Allemagne où il expliquaiit que le
nuage avait franchi leur propre
frontière. Et donc il nous a fallu
plusieurs jours pour que l'on fasse
comprendre pour que l'on convainque
les journalistes du service scientifique
queon ne pouvait pas rester sur cette
position puisque la Suède et l'Allemagne
nous expliquer que le le nuage n'avait
pas franchi les frontières de la France.
Donc le professeur Pèlerin qui
n'arrêtait pas d'expliquer que si on
faisait des moyennes, il y avait rien à
craindre. Sauf qu'il oublié de dire
qu'en Core et dans l'est, il y avait des
taux de radioactivité qui étaient très
élevés. a été viré de
n' été comment dire interdit d'antenne.
Il a été remplacé par le ministre de
l'industrie de l'époque qui s'appelait
Madelin et et après alors bien après
l'OMS a a effectivement démontré que ce
qu'avait raconté le lobby nucléaire
était était pas juste. Alors le procès
c'est un procès qui m'est arrivé mais
bien longtemps après en 2000 j'étais
l'invité d'une émission de Thierry
Hardisson, je sais plus comment il
s'appelle mais il fait toujours la même
sous des titres différents avec Michel
Polac et Michel Polac c'était un grand
lecteur. J'ai découvert beaucoup
d'auteurs grâce à ce que à ce
qu'écrivait au conseil de Michel Polac
et Michel Polac évoque au cours de cette
émission le livre d'une d'une auteur qui
est devenue depuis prix Nobel qui
s'appelle Svetlana Alexevic qui a écrit
trois grands livres sur le l'Union
soviétique. Le premier sur l'Afghanistan
qui s'appelle cercueil de fer, le second
sur Ternobyl qui s'appelle la
supplication et le troisième qui
s'appelle la fin de l'homme rouge. de ce
qu'elle appelle des livres de paroles où
elle recueille des témoignages et la
supplication c'est un livre formidable
sur Ternobyl. Et donc il évoque ce livre
et moi ça me rappelle ce que j'avais
vécu en 86
pendant le journal et je dis "Ah tiens,
mais c'est je me souviens du professeur
Pèlerin d'un sinistre personnage, voilà
exactement ce que j'ai dit, d'un
sinistre personnage qui s'appelait le
professeur Pèlerin et qui venait nous
expliquer que le nuage n'a pas franchi
les frontières de la France. Et le
professeur Pèlerin ne m'a pas attaqué
pour sinistre personnage en diffamation
mais parce qu'il n'a jamais prononcé le
mot le nuage n'a pas franchi les
frontières de la France". raison
donc j'ai perdu en première instance
j'ai perdu non il avait pas raison parce
que il avait menti sur les effets du
nuage. Donc mais c'est ça que je moi je
voulais dire. Donc j'ai été condamné en
première instance en appel en cassation
et mon avocat Antoine Comte m'a dit on
ne peut pas en rester là. Et donc on est
allé devant la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui a condamné le
gouvernement français et je suis revenu
devant les tribunaux pour que cette
diffamation soit supprimée en casier
judiciaire et ça s'appelait l'arrêt ma
mère. Voilà.
Très bien. L'arrê ma mère, ça ça passe
bien.
C'est un nom facile hein. C'est un nom
qui peut être interprété dans tous les
sens.
Tout à fait. Je vous pose une question.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous mettre dans
la peau d'un journaliste qui nous
annonce les armes de destruction massive
d' de Saddam Hussein ? Hm
hm.
Est-ce que vous pensez que tous les
journalistes qui nous ont annoncé ça à
longueur de journée ont eu une conduite
introspective ? Non, je pense qu'ils se
sont
Est-ce qu'il y a eu un meilleakoupa des
chaînes de télé ?
Aucun. Mais vous n'avez jamais vu de
meilleakulpa des chaînes de télé ni des
d'ailleurs euh ce serait injuste de
n'attaquer que les chaînes de télé quand
des journaux de la presse écrite mettent
en une affichent en une euh des et des
gens qui dont on ne sait même pas s'ils
sont coupables ou innocents et dont on
découvre l'innocence. Après, vous les
avez vu vous excusez vous, ces gens qui
dans la vie peut-être totalement
chamboulé. par Nicolas Sarkozi là,
ça c'est autre chose. Euh la justice est
là pour pour [raclement de gorge] faire
la la vérité et j'espère que les juges
d'instruction qui sont en charge de
cette affaire ne vont pas la laisser
tomber.
Quelle indignité ! [rires]
Mais mais la réalité c'est quoi ? c'est
que en effet les c'est ça fait partie
d'une forme d'arrogance de la presse. On
considère que une fois que c'est dit,
c'est dit et qu'on a pas revenir en
arrière. De toute façon, tout le monde
l'aura oublié. Maintenant, il y a des
gens qui l'oublient pas. d'abord ceux
chez qui ça laisse des traces durables,
il ne l'oublie pas parce que ça peut
chambouler leur vie et les les les
plonger dans de dans de profonde
dépression et puis parce que la logique
voudrait qu'en effet il y ait non pas un
monde honorable de la presse mais
qu'elle reconnaisse ses erreurs. Alors
pour la la petite réponse qui a été
apportée euh je pense que ça date des
années 80, c'est pas si vieux que ça
finalement, c'est le médiateur.
Donc par exemple sur France Inter une
fois par mois, vous avez la médiatrice
qui répond à des questions des à des
réflexions des auditeurs qui ont estimé
que tel ou tel reportage ou tel ou tel
éditorial était biaisé. Selon c'est
hérité c'est hérité de d'une vieille
de comment dire d'une d'une règle qui
existe d'une coutume qui existe
principalement dans les pays
anglo-saxons
que nous avons copié qui s'appelle
Lombunsman qui existe depuis longtemps.
Par exemple, la presse américaine, je
pense en particulier au New York Times
et à d'autres grands journaux,
lorsqu'ils commettent lorsqu'il
lorsqu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont affirmé et
remis en cause et que la vérité non pas
alternative parce que ce mot-là est
absolument effroyable, mais lorsque la
vérité est établie qu'ils se sont
trompés, ils le disent et le
reconnaissent. Ce n'est pas le cas dans
notre dans notre pays où il y a cette
espèce de poids euh
de de
Ouais. de la télé. Moi quand j'étais
journaliste et que je présentais des
journaux, on était que deux journaux,
que deux chaînes, deux grandes chaînes
qui avaient un journal à 13h, c'était
TF1 et antenne 2. Vous imaginez le poids
qui était le bon peut-être il y avait
moins de moins de récepteur de télé,
mais c'était énorme. Aujourd'hui, le
c'est c'est complètement explosé, hein.
Il y a il y a je sais pas combien de
chaînes. Ça veut pas dire pour autant
que l'influence est multipliée par
autant de chaînes. Non, je ne crois pas.
Mais euh et de toute façon, je pense
qu'il faut aussi que l'on soit
comment dire euh euh que l'on soit h euh
[grognement]
équilibré avec ça parce que on se rend
compte que ce sont pas les télés qui
font euh les élections, hein. Euh par
exemple, quand on a accusé l'heure de
vérité qui était une émission politique
des années 80 qui avait invité Le Pen,
vous avez entendu à plusieurs reprises
euh la Vox Populi ou certains
commentateurs et observateurs dirent que
Le Pen, le succès de Le Pen, c'était la
faute à la télé à l'heure de vérité.
Mais c'est une équivoque totale. Le Pen,
il est né dans la société. Et si le Pen
a prospéré, c'est sur les renoncements
de la gauche, sur les complaisces de la
droite, les odeurs de Chirak et tout ce
que tout ce qui a pu être toutes les
concessions qui ont été faites à
l'extrême droite avec des gens qui sont
allés braconner sur leur terre. C'est ça
qui a fait prospérer Le Pen, c'est pas
la télé. Et Giscar, on disait qu'il
tenait la télé quand j'y étais. Ben
Giscar, il a été battu par Miteran. Donc
la les télés, elles n'influencent que
aux marges aux marges mais c'est pas
elles qui font l'élection.
Est-ce que vous êtes sûr de ça ?
J'en suis certain. La preuve- viorter.
Est-ce que vous pensez pas Est-ce que
vous pensez pas que le fait je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable, est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez pas
que le fait qu'on ne parle pas des gens
qui votent votent extrême droite ou
qu'on les décrive à chaque fois comme
des fronts plats, des cutéreux, des
arrièricatau
ou des choses comme ça ? Est-ce que ça
les pousse pas à se radicaliser à chaque
fois ? Est-ce que le journaliste de
tendance extrême gauche formé dans une
université d'extrême gauche issue d'un
milieu où l'extrême gauche se se
gargarise de sa de sa de son côté
intellectuel ?
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que le fait
d'avoir deux prismes de lecture
totalement opposé ne génère pas de la
radicalisation
de l'autre côté du micro, de l'autre
côté de la caméra ? C'estàd que quand on
voit
l'avocat du diable hein, quand on voit à
chaque fois tout le temps tout le temps
alors toujours les mêmes présentés comme
des attardés, est-ce que vous poussez
est-ce que vous pensez pas que c'est
cette presse, cette télévision qui les
pousse à se radicaliser ? Je prends le
même exemple avec les antivacins.
À chaque fois les décrire comme des
demeurés, bon, on va dire qu'il y en a
certains, ils en ont une sacrée couche
quand même. Mais à chaque fois de ne pas
avoir cette bienveillance ne pousse-t-il
pas à ce qu'il se radicalise ? Et le
pire, qu'il se taise.
Alors
euh
là encore, il y a les il y a des
réponses dans les questions que vous
posez. Non euh je ne suis pas du tout
convaincu de ce que vous dites sur les
journalistes d'extrême gauche. D'abord à
la télé il y en a pas de journalistes
d'extrême gauche. Ils sont tout de suite
éliminé.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que justement ils sont
considérés comme subversifs. Et donc la
pensée dominante, elle n'est pas
d'extrême gauche que je sache. Donc
quand on est d'extrême gauche et bien on
se réfugie dans des
dans des journaux en ligne.
La libération.
Non, libération c'est pas d'extrême
gauche. C'est pas d'extrême gauche. Mais
il y a je ne les connais pas mais je
sais qu'il y en a. Je par exemple est-ce
que c'est d'extrême gauche ? Il y a il y
a des il y a des lieux de réflexion très
intéressants. Je pense par exemple le
vent se lève
euh
une autre qui s'appelle
lundi matin. Bon ce sont des ce sont
beaucoup d'intellectuels
et aussi de journalistes qui sont plutôt
radicaux que vous pouvez qualifier à
l'extrême gauche. Je sais pas si on peut
leur attribuer ce titre là.
Oh il y a ultra gauche.
Comment
il y a ultra gauche ? Ultra gauche, ça
c'est une ça s'était inventé par madame
Alli Marie et et son cabinet noir pour
mieux stigmatiser les gens de Tarnac et
tout ça c'est une invention. Bah vous
avez, c'est très bien que vous parliez
d'ultragauche parce que ça a été inventé
par un cabinet euh de droite qui voulait
euh diaboliser les gens de Tarnac après
ce qu'on a après toutes les aventures
que que l'on a connu pour essayer de
démontrer qui c'étaient euh les
responsables. Tout simplement parce que
Coupa et ses copains sont qualifiés
comme des gens subversifs parce qu'ils
ont une pensée radicale etéronome, on va
dire euh et ça ne plaisait pas au
pouvoir parce que le pouvoir en avait
peur comme il a eu peur de Notredame
d'élande. Ça veut dire que c'est une que
quand on a peur de gens comme ceux qui
sont à Notred Dame d'and ou qu'on a peur
des gens de Tarnac
ou des gilets jaunes
ou des gilets jaunes je sais pas à
l'opposé d'ailleurs ou des gilets
jaunes. Ça veut dire que ça veut dire
que la démocratie est très faible
puisqu'elle a peur de elle a peur de non
pas de son nombre mais elle a peur de
tout ce qui lui renvoie ses ses ses
défaillances, tout ce qui lui renvoie au
visage comme un miroir ses renoncements
et et ses complaisces. Mais ultra
gauche, c'est en effet un mot qui a été
inventé par le cabinet euh d'Alomarie,
un mot typique de la propagande euh et
qui a été repris comme un seul homme qui
a été repris comme un seul homme par
l'ensemble de la presse. Voilà. Et et
donc c'est vrai que les journalistes se
précipitent bien souvent sans vérifier
sur ce qu'on leur donne à manger d'une
certaine manière
parce qu'on les a affamé derrière avant
on les a affamé
donc ils se
non les journalistes ne sont pas affamés
mais ils sont
les journalistes sont affamés quand
même.
Ils sont affamés de ils sont affamés de
scoop ils sont affamés de bruit ils sont
affamés de buzz médiatique pour beaucoup
d'entre
pulièrement ils sont affamés la plupart
des journalistes
affamés dans quel sens ?
Bah ils gagnent pas un radis.
Ah bon ? Non mais ça c'est autre chose
mais que ça n'a rien à voir.
Le statut social et l'économie du
journalisme.
Comment on fait pour qu'un chien obéisse
? À votre époque, on faisait comment ?
J'ai jamais eu chien donc je peux pas
vous dire comment on fait pour que
c'est soit on leur tape sur la gueule
soit on les affamme.
Non, on peut peut-être il y a peut-être
d'autres méthodes pour faire
méode. Est-ce que les journalistes c'est
un peu pareil ? C'est-à-dire que on leur
donne pas à manger, on leur donne des
salaires de misère. Hm.
Et ensuite on leur dit maintenant vous
allez rapporter donc ils mordent tout ce
qui bougent, ils attrapent tout ce qui
bou. Je ce que je vous expliquais tout à
l'heure, dans la mesure où une très
grande major très grande partie des
journalistes est dans la précarité, ces
journalistes là peuvent être en effet un
terrain un terro favorable pour aller
chercher y compris dans les poubelles.
Enfin pour aller ça, on est bien
d'accord mais ce n'est pas une raison
suffisante pour euh qualifier tous ces
journalistes de fouille poubelle et de
fouille merne, il faut dire les mots
comme ils sont. Moi, j'en ai vu beaucoup
de ces ce qu'on appelle en fait, ils
appartiennent à quelle catégorie ? Ils
appartiennent à la catégorie qu'on
appelle les intellectuels précaires.
Bon, vous allez aller dans une grande
radio, aller dans des grandes émissions
de télé qui sont pas produites par les
télés mais par des producteurs. Vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui préparent ces
émissions qui sont des précaurs qui vont
aller travailler pendant 3 semaines ou
un mois ou de mois à tel endroit, une
période de chômage et puis tous ces
gens-là, ils étaient où ? Il suffisait
d'aller à nuit debout. pendant la
période de nuit debout, vous alliez
place de la République. J'habite à côté.
C'est pas parce que j'habite à côté que
j'y allais d'ailleurs, c'est parce que
c'était intéressant. Et vous aviez
beaucoup beaucoup de de ceux qui étaient
à nuit debout. C'était ce qu'on appelle
des intellectuels précaires. Et ces
intellectuels précaires aujourd'hui avec
la crise de la la COVID-19, ils sont
particulièrement menacés et encore plus
fragilisés et encore plus vulnérable. Et
je ne parle pas de tous ceux que l'on
appelle les invisibles et qu'on commence
justement à voir sur les écrans de télé.
C'est peut-être un des aspects et disons
un effet collatéral euh qui peut être
considéré comme positif puisque ça rend
visible euh la misère dans laquelle se
trouve un certain nombre de Français.
Euh aujourd'hui euh je crois que le
chiffre qui a été donné euh ce matin au
moment où l'on parle, c'est 100 millions
de Français qui son qui sont aujourd'hui
en dessous du euh du seuil de pauvreté.
Et ça c'est un chiffre effrayant. C'est
un chiffre effrayant. Et donc en effet,
je le souvenir puisqueon a le temps d'en
parler. Pendant le premier confinement,
j'avais vu un j'avais lu un un excellent
reportage d'une journaliste du monde qui
s'appelle Couvler sur la situation à
Clichi, Clichi Sous Bois. Euh un
reportage qui montrait comment des
familles qui par exemple pouvaient
bénéficier de la cantine, la cantine
c'est 1 € donc il y a plus de cantine.
Bah pour nourrir votre enfant ça va vous
coûter plus d'un €. donc des familles
qui se trouvaient subitement d'abord
dans un confinement qui était en en
nette surpopulation
euh et avec un budget qui n'arrivait pas
à à nourrir la famille. Et donc j'ai
j'avais vu dans ce reportage que
l'association assé le feu de mon copain
Mohamed Meschmach
était très active pour venir en aide à
ses familles. J'ai appelé Mohamed qui
m'a dit et en effet s'il n'y avait pas
eu, si on éétait pas là et s'il y avait
pas ses associations pour les aider à
pour les pour les aider à se nourrir en
fait hein et à subvenir à leurs besoins,
il y aurait il y aurait des des
explosions, enfin il y aurait des des
situations plus que critiques et on les
voit aujourd'hui. Regardez les camps de
migrants, le camp de migrant qui est au
nord de Paris où déjà est en train
d'apparaître une maladie comme la gale
que l'on croyait éradiqué. Donc c'est
vrai que la Covid a accéléré les
inégalités qui est quand même
aujourd'hui le mal principal de notre
société.
Revenons à nos fake news.
La dernière fake news fake news que vous
vous ayez vu annoncer
sur le service public. Vous avez vu quoi
comme fake news la dernière fois
annoncer sur le service public ?
Vous voulez dire en tant que ? en tant
que spectateur
euh je sais plus je sais plus d'abord
parce que pour ne rien vous cacher, je
regarde pas beaucoup les journaux. Alors
ça
relevance.
Oui, je paye ma relevance. Oui. Oui.
Mais je regarde très peu les journaux.
Normalement à votre âge c'est pas
gratuit la redevance.
Je ne crois pas. Non non. Faudrait
demander à ma femme mais je sais pas.
Non
non non je la paye la redevance.
Pourquoi elle serait gratuite pour moi ?
Je sais pas. À partir de la carte
vermeil, je crois qu'on a une redevance
gratuite. Non.
Oui oui non mais c'est en fonction des
revenus. Non
c'est vrai. Vous avez peut-être raison.
On va demander à notre communauté de fa
check et ça.
Oui oui en fait je suis pas
la dernière grosse fake news que vous
ayez entendu sur le service public. Vous
vous en rappelez pas, c'était que
Ternobyl c'était quoi les armes de il y
a longtemps. Entre-temps, il y a eu sans
doute d'autres fake news. Mais alors,
est-ce que les Français il y a eu la la
l'immense fake news, c'était celle de
celle de Bush Bush le fils sur le les
armes de destruction massive ? Là, ça a
[raclement de gorge] été, j'allais dire
c'est le contraire puisque on a eu le
vilpin qui avec un certain panache
d'ailleurs à préposition à
l'Organisation des Nations- Unies contre
la l'explication du Coline Powell.
à l'époque encore des services de
renseignement essayant prouver essayant
de prouver que oui, cela dit euh euh
[grognement] la France n'était pas blanc
bleu si je puis dire à Saddam Hussein.
Rappelons-nous de la visite de Chirak à
Saddam Hussein et nous l'avons beaucoup
aidé ce ceux,
c'est ça ?
Oui, absolument. Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Donc on a essayé de lui vendre du
nucléaire
et donc la la France a une
responsabilité évidemment dans le a eu
une responsabilité dans la prospérité de
de Saddam Hussein de la même manière
qu'elle en a eu dans la prospérité de de
Kaddafi qui était pourant
est-ce que la France du
mais mais ce jour-là en effet la fake
news elle été aux États-Unis et
peut-être dans d'autres pays affidé aux
États-Unis mais pas en France mais la
dernière fake news pourquoi vous Vous
avez une vous avez un exemple à me
donner ?
Je je vous pose la question. Est-ce que
est-ce que pour vous le départ de
l'épidémie du Covid ça a été
Ah oui, en effet. Alors la dernière fake
news, c'est quand le professeur Salomon
qui est un petit peu le clone du
professeur pèlerin de Ternobyl en 1986.
Attention, pas de diffamation chez nous,
hein.
Je Non, non, je ne je ne pas du tout à
diffamer Salomon, mais on peut on peut
faire le parallèle entre 86 Ternobyl, le
responsable du nucléaire qui vient vous
expliquer qu'il y a pas de risque, qu'il
y a pas de problème. Et puis 40 ans plus
tard, en 2019, le le directeur de la
santé qui vient vous expliquer qu'il y a
pas besoin de masque alors qu'il sait
perfamment avec le gouvernement qu'ils
n'ont pas assez de masques, qu'il n'y a
pas eu de renouvellement en des masques,
que ces masques ont été périmés.
Oui. Que ces masques n'étaient plus
Ça c'est une fake news en effet.
Oui, mais il faut il faut aussi lui dire
merci.
Pourquoi faudrait lui dire merci ?
Z-vous un vent de panique
dans une population qui est un désœuvré,
paniqué, atterré en perte de confiance.
Est-ce que après 2 ans de gilet jaune,
le fait que Salomon mente
consciemment [grognement] enfin
il est pas le seul, il a menti au nom
des autres hein.
Oui.
Oui. Non mais c'est pas c'est une
responsabilité solidaire. Donc est-ce
que c'était pas un geste patriotique
de dire tout va bien se passer les
enfants, continuez à aramer parce que
sinon ça va être compliqué.
Oui, on va on peut l'analyser comme ça
si vous voulez mais
l'avocat du diable.
Oui mais moi je sais pas
d'abord pour croire au diable il faut
croire au bon Dieu. Donc à chacun
à chacun ici de nous dire ce qu'il en
pense.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Si j'ai un imaginaire moi.
Non. Est-ce que vous avez un ami
imaginaire ?
Est-ce que j'ai un ami imaginaire ?
Croyez en Dieu.
J'ai été élevé chez les prêtres. Oui.
J'ai même fait j'ai même fait la totale.
J'ai été élevé chez les prêtres, les
bonnes sœurs et les jésuites.
Et votre côté
et quand ma mère se désespérait, ma mère
ma maman se désespérait de ne pas me
voir aller à la messe avec mes frères,
je disais "Maman, il y a pas de
problème. On a 150 ans de messe d'avance
devant nous puisqu'on allait à la messe
tous les jours quand on était chez les
prêtres."
Donc oui, j'ai été élevé dans la
religion catholique, ce qui ne m'empêche
pas de aujourd'hui de croire d'abord en
l'homme.
Mais vous y croyez ou pour vous c'est
une fable comme le Père Noël ?
Je pense que je ne sais pas si on peut
dire que c'est une fable comme le père
Noël, mais non, je n'y crois pas. Non,
je disons que je suis agnostique
maintenant. Vous attendez plus en
dessous du sapin.
[soupir][souffle coupé]
Oh, j'ai longtemps attendu au dessous du
sapin. Mais et le sapin c'est pas de
toute façon et je pense que le sapin
c'est beaucoup plus profane que ça.
C'est lié à la religion mais c'est lié
surtout le sapin. C'est quand vous
parliez de la marchandisation de
l'information, le sapin c'est une
manière de marchandiser la religion.
C'est-à-dire, on l'a fait entrer dans le
domaine séculier, mais c'était
uniquement pour des raisons finalement
des raisons souvent très commerciales.
Quel était ma première question juste
avant l'histoire du sapin ?
Votre première question c'était de me
demander qu'elle a été euh elle c'était
demandé si j'avais un ami imaginaire et
la question d'avant c'était de me
demander si quelle était ma ma dernière
vision, enfin mon dernier constat de
fake news. Et en effet, je ne m'en
souvenais pas. C'était je l'ai évoqué
devant vous grâce à vous. C'est la
question la question du masque. Je ne
suis pas d'accord avec votre analyse. Je
pense que ce gouvernement comme beaucoup
d'autres sans doute à la sa place euh
était paniqué devant l'ampleur que
prenait la pandémie. Mais vous savez en
fait cette première réaction
de de la du gouvernement face à la
pandémie, c'est conforme d'ailleurs à ce
qui est dominant dans nos sociétés.
C'est le déni. De la même manière que
euh on pratique le déni face au
dérèglement climatique et à
l'effondrement de la biodiversité et à
ses conséquences pour euh l'espèce
humaine. De la même manière, on a on on
a été dans le déni vis-à-vis euh par
rapport aux pandémies. On se croit c'est
ce que c'est c'est c'est la question de
la démesure et de la puissance. L'homme
moderne de nos sociétés modernes dites
modernes se pense tellement puissant
qu'il se croit invincible. Donc on n pas
tiré les leçons de Ébola, on n pas tiré
les leçons
du sida, on n' pas tiré les leçons du
premier SRAS, ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs
les asiatiques avec plus de pertinence
parce qu'on considérait que on était
épargné. Et d'ailleurs, j'ai entendu
cette semaine quand euh Pfizer a annoncé
euh la mise au point euh d'un nouveau
euh d'un nouveau vaccin, j'ai entendu un
inffectionologue dire "C'est génial, ils
ont trouvé une méthode qui est
totalement révolutionnaire. Grâce à ça,
nous n'aurons plus jamais de pandémie où
nous pourrons résister à toutes les
pandémies." Et ben encore une fois, on
fonctionne dans le déni, on fonctionne
dans cette idée selon laquelle la
technique, comme le disait si bienul
pourrait nous protéger de tout sans
remettre en cause les raisons qui
conduisent à la situation dans laquelle
on se trouve. Parce que euh la question
de la pandémie, elle est pas arrivée
comme ça. C'est ce qu'on appelle les
zonoses. C'est quoi une zooose ? C'est
quand l'homme se rapproche de plus en
plus du monde sauvage. Or comme bah oui,
mais c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer. Plus vous déforestez
pour nourrir avec du soja transgénique
euh les bestiaux que nous que nous
mangeons ici, plus vous vous rapprochez
du monde sauvage, plus vous vous
rapprochez d'un monde qui est porteur de
virus qui n'est qui sont pas pathogènes
pour lui mais pathogènes pour l'homme.
Donc continuons comme ça et d'autres
pandémies encore plus létal nous en
connaîtrons.
Revenons à notre ami Jérôme Salomon.
Oui.
Et à notre ami le gouvernement. Vous
trouvez pas qu'ils ont pas bien agi ?
Je ne sais pas s'ils ont pas bien agi au
départ. Ils n'ont ils ont agi avec les
moyens d'humour. Que vouliez-vous qu'il
disent ? Ils n'avaient pas le masque.
Donc ils étaient obligés de mentir, de
dire le masque ça le masque ça sert à
rien. Oui. Donc ils étaient complètement
démunis.
Est-ce qu'il pouvait dire à la société
qu'il commençait à avoir une grande
trouille ? Est-ce qu'il pouvait dire à
la société qu'ils étaient démunis ?
Qu'il servaient à rien en fait ?
Bah la réponse est non. La réponse est
est non parce que la la réaction de la
société aurait été aurait été terrible.
D'ailleurs, pas du tout par pas
simplement par rapport à la survie du
gouvernement en terme politique, mais du
point de vue du point de vue sociétal.
la société déjà qu'on est dans un monde
où de plus en plus qui ressemble de plus
en plus à ce que raconte Hops sur
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme là on
serait on serait entré dans un on serait
entré dans une logique absolument
effroyable. Finalement euh on a eu
plutôt de la chance mais ce qu'il faut
dire aussi c'est que il y avait pas
simplement un brème de masque
c'était aussi payé au prix le plus
élevé. C'est ce que on est, c'est ce que
les soignants sont en train de de payer
cher. Le titre du monde d'aujourd'hui,
c'est la grande fatigue des soignants.
C'est que on a payé le prix de politique
menée par la gauche et par la droite de
de privatisation, non pas de
privatisation mais de marchandisation
des des hôpitaux ou en tout cas de
réduction de moyens, hein, souvenez-vous
de de la loi sur les hôpitaux à
l'activité. Donc, il fallait que ça
rapporte de l'argent. on a supprimé des
lits. Donc le résultat et ben il est là
et aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
à laquelle on ne on ne peut pas faire
face et on est à chaque fois sur une sur
une ligne de crète qui peut amener à qui
peut amener à comme c'est le cas en ce
moment en Italie à une situation que
l'on ne que l'on ne contrôle plus. Et
alors ce qui est dingue c'est qu'entre
le premier confinement et aujourd'hui le
second confinement on nous avait dit on
va augmenter de 12000 lit ce qui n'a pas
été le cas. Ce qui était un gros
mensonge d'abord parce que pour ajouter
des leaders à animation, il faut compter
à peu près trois à quatre personnes pour
s'occuper de ces leader animation et la
formation de ces soignants qui sont très
spécialisés c'està dire entre 3 et 4
ans. Mais comment on a réduit le
personnel soignant ? Voilà où on en est
où on en est aujourd'hui. Donc c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que tout ça, tout ce
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui, toute
cette ce sentiment de fragilité, cette
obligation que nous avons de ne plus
être en contact les uns avec les autres,
cette naissance d'une société sans
contact qui ne fait qu'enrichir
d'ailleurs les les géants du numérique.
C'est c'est lié aussi à au à des
politiques publiques qui ont conduit à
un retrait de ce que l'on doit au
public, à un retrait de de qui n'ont qui
n'ont fait de la santé qu'une variable
d'ajustement. Or aujourd'hui là, il est
clair que on doit considérer que que la
santé est la priorité des priorités dans
toutes les sociétés modernes. Fake news
et revenons à la défiance. Hm
hm. Est-ce que vous pensez pas que c'est
le gouvernement qui est le plus grand
propagateur de défiance au sein même de
sa population ? À force de raconter des
conneries, à force de s'arranger avec la
vérité, à force de s'arranger avec
l'actualité, est-ce que maintenant il
n'est pas trop tard dans une grande
partie de l'opinion publique pour
retrouver confiance dans ces instances
dirigeantes ? Je ne peux pas le dire
aujourd'hui, mais les ingrédients pour
euh la l'érosion euh encore plus grande
de la confiance de cette partie de la
population sont là. En effet, on voit
bien que alors je pense que ce serait
euh exagéré d'attribuer la seule
responsabilité à ce gouvernement. C'est
une responsabilité qui vient de loin.
Non, mais quand
la défiance vis-à-vis de de du monde
politique, elle ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui. C'est c'est elle s'est
construite cette défiance. Mais dans le
même sac, on met les écoles qui ont
formé cette upper class, les les les
tout.
Oui.
Oui. Mais c'est pas parce que vous
supprimez les NA que pour autant vous
supprimez la formation des erc classs.
Euh Bourdieu l'a expliqué beaucoup mieux
que moi sur la reproduction et je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi on supprimerait
science Po l'idée c'est de faire de
permettre l'accès à sciences pot de
toutes les catégories sociales. Mais ça
veut dire qu'avant non c'est pas comme
vous dites et on le voit pas. C'est pas
que du violon, c'est aussi comment
qu'est-ce quel est quel est le rôle que
l'on donne à l'école et est-ce que
est-ce que on va faire les efforts
nécessaires pour que l'école elle aille
partout y compris dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des territoires oubliés de
la République ? Ce qui est ce qui est
est d'ailleurs effrayant. On entend le
discours politique du politique qui
ressort tout de suite.
Non, pas du tout, pas du tout.
On va revenir sur l'école et et
l'hôpital juste après.
Revenons, revenons à
C'est la reproduction évidemment.
Évidemment, c'est la reproduction quand
vous êtes dans une famille qui a les
moyens
de vous suivre par exemple comme pendant
le confinement. Pendant le confinement,
celui qui est en situation de survie, il
va se préoccuper d'abord de sa survie
plutôt que de l'éducation de ses enfants
qui ne vont plus à l'école. Ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une série, il y a
toute une partie de la population
française qu'on appelle les décrocheurs.
Vous avez des profs, des institutes qui
ne revoient plus un certain nombre de
leurs élèves et qui ne les reverront
plus. Ceuxlà, ils sont passés par prof
et perte du on va dire du néolibéralisme
de de d'une société qui considère qu'en
effet il y a un certain nombre de gens
qu'on ne reverra pas qui peut-être comme
ça a été le cas en 2005 se révolteront
et puis on mattra la révolte et puis
voilà puis on oubliera et puis
entre-temps d'ailleurs on votera des
lois qui permettront de réduire encore
un petit peu plus de rétrécir encore un
petit peu plus nos libertés comme la
dernière sur les et qui est censé
répondre aux questions de sécurité
générale et qui juge sur l'intention,
j'ai jamais vu ça dans le loi français.
Bref, euh et à faire des flics euh
effectivement, à donner encore un petit
peu plus d'impunité aux flics. Bon, tout
ça en effet ne peut que contribuer
à nourrir ce que ce sur quoi j'insiste,
le ressentiment d'une partie de la
population qui va même peut-être, et
c'est là où votre question est
intéressante, qui qui va peut-être même
organiser son invisibilité par rapport à
par rapport au pouvoir et se réveiller
sous des formes qui peuvent être
extrêmement extrêmement dures. Je pense
qu'on est à la veille. On n pas encore
vu des des
Peut-être qu'un jour on se dira bah
finalement les gilets jaunes cétait
plutôt sympa
ou les mec
ah ou les
Oui. Les mecs de l'ultra gauche c'était
plutôt sympa parce que ils étaient ils
écrivaient des bouquins et ils venaient
pas.
Il y avait pas explosion en effet. Mais
en effet, on peut se retrouver dans des
situations
de de tel
que du désenchantement, de tel sentiment
d'injustice, de tel ressentiment
vis-à-vis d'une autre partie de la
population. C'est comme s'il y avait
deux Frances ou trois Frances même euh
que euh on verra euh on verra exploser
euh dans certaines parties du pays euh
des formes de révolte qui seront
extrêmement dures et qui seront
réprimées d'une manière très brutale et
très violente.
Elles justifieront d'ailleurs,
malheureusement ça justifiera des
régimes autoritaires hein. C'est cher.
J'en arrive à la deuxième partie de ma
question qui est les préconisations pour
éviter d'en arriver là. Parce queon est
bien d'accord que le pouvoir en place ou
le l'administration en place chargé de
faire le maintien de l'ordre s'y attend.
On le voit dans la la militarisation de
l'espace urbain, la militarisation des
procédures. On le voit bien, on le sent
bien. Mais vous en tant que vieux
journaliste,
en tant que musée du journalisme,
vous êtes pas sympa de me placer dans
les musétiquetés. Non.
Non, je sais pas. Non, je peux quand
même pas encore muséation. Est-ce que
vous avez des préconisations
à donner soit à vos confrères, soit au
gouvernement pour éviter d'en d'en
arriver là ?
D'abord, les préconisations, elles
peuvent pas venir d'un seul homme ou
d'une seule personne. Ça, c'est croire à
l'homme providentiel.
Et nous avons dans ma famille politique
toujours combattu cette idée extrêmement
pernicieuse.
Les préconisations, elle sont simple.
Que ce soit par rapport au terrorisme,
que ce soit par rapport aux tentatives
de réduction de nos libertés, que ce
soit par rapport même aux conséquences
que peut entraîner une pandémie comme la
COVID, une conséquence et des
conséquences politiques. La seule
préconisation, c'est de défendre l'état
de droit. c'est de défendre nos libertés
et c'est de les préserver et c'est de
battre se battre contre tous ceux qui
veulent les remettre en cause, contre
tous ceux qui prétexte d'un événement
particulier ou d'une succession
d'événements pour réduire encore un
petit peu plus nos libertés, ce qui à
court terme apporte de la satisfaction à
la société parce qu'elle a peur mais qui
à moyen terme et à long terme devient
dangereux. Pourquoi j'ai fait partie des
six députés qui se sont opposés à la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence après
les attentats du Bataclan ? Parce que
nous avions dit les S réfuseniques, nous
avions dit que des prolongations comme
celle-ci, il y en aurait d'autres. Il y
en a effectivement eu d'autres. On était
en train dans d'entrer dans une spirale
qui a d'une certaine manière non pas
englouti mais rétréci euh nos libertés.
Et ça s'est terminé comment ? Bah quand
euh Macron est arrivé au pouvoir, il a
fait entrer dans le droit communs
qui étaient vendues comme des
dispositions d'exception.
Voilà dans quelle spirale on est en
train d'entrer. Et vous avez pas tort de
dire que ce le gouvernement sait très
bien qu'il peut être confronté à des
situations explosives. C'est la raison
pour laquelle il militarise de plus en
plus la société et il l'accompagne de
réduction de nos libertés en favorisant
d'ailleurs un petit peu plus cette
militérisation. C'est les c'est
l'exemple de l'interdiction de diffuser
les images de policiers pendant des
manifestations. Heureusement qu'il y a
eu des gens comme Dufren et quelques
militants solides euh et quelques ONG
pour montrer ce qui était devenu euh
l'impunité de la police dans un certain
nombre de manifestations. Heureusement
que des avocats se sont euh associés
pour défendre les victimes de violence
policière. Mais vous savez, tout ça a
commencé bien plus tôt qu'on ne le
croit. Il se trouve qu'après la mort de
Réy Fres, la mort tragique de Réy Fres
euh euh à Syvince, nous avions encore le
groupe écologiste à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Nos auditeurs qui étaient Réi ? Réy Fra
c'est un jeune Réy Fres c'était un jeune
militant écolo qui était qui a rejoint
les Lazade la zone à défendre de Sivin
qui existait depuis plusieurs mois qui
se battait contre un barrage qui devait
se faire à destination des hirigants de
maïs et qui étaiit
qui ne s'inscrivaiit pas du tout dans la
logique de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et qui ne pouvait que
contribuer un petit peu plus épuiser la
ressource en eau. Donc c'était une
bagarre décolo en fait hein. Et ce jeune
Rémy Fres, il est il est venu rejoindre
un soir les militants et il a été tué
par une grenade tiré par un garde mobile
qui défendait d'ailleurs un endroit qui
était qui n'avait pas à être défendu,
qui était un chantier une semaine avant,
je je à une semaine avant ce drame, j'y
suis allé avec Cécile Duflot sur sur le
terrain où on a rencontré les adistes,
on a rencontré le préfet qui avait une
relation extrêmement tendue avec les les
militants sur place qui n'avaient même
pas daigné parler au porte-parole que
l'on a amené avec nous dans le bureau du
préfet et on lui a dit "Vous savez,
monsieur le préfet si vous faites pas un
effort de discussion
et et de compréhension, il risque de se
passer des choses graves." Une semaine
après, Réy FR était était tué
tragiquement et après ça, nous avons
demandé une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur le maintien de
l'ordre. Euh la tradition veut qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale, lorsqu'il y a euh
une une [grognement] instance
judiciaire, une procédure judiciaire, on
ne peut pas demander une commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur le cas
précis. Donc on l'a pas demandé sur Emy
Fres. Et donc le le la commission
d'enquête parlementaire, le son titre
c'était euh comment assurer comment
adapter le maintien de l'ordre. C'était
ça l'idée. Comment adapter le l'ordre à
la liberté d'expression et au droit de
manifester.
Donc j'ai comme c'était une initiative
qui parlait de notre qui est partait de
notre groupe euh je n'ai j'ai été
président de ce de cette commission
d'enquête parlementaire mais le groupe
socialiste a refusé que j'en sois le
rapporteur et c'est en général le
rapporteur qui a le plus de pouvoir dans
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
puisque c'est par rapport c'est sur son
rapport que la commission vote.
[grognement]
Et comme je sentais le souffre pour le
PS, je n'ai été que président. Donc
pendant 6 mois, tous les jeudis, nous
avons auditionné
différents acteurs venant de tous les
milieux, y compris d'ailleurs des jeunes
qui avaient été blessés par des tirs de
tazer, le tazer dont nous avions demandé
en 2000 l'interdiction par une
proposition de loi qui évidemment a été
rejetée à cette époque. Et le rapporteur
était un proche de Manuel Vals. C'était
un des spécialistes, paraît-il, de la
sécurité à au PS qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle Pascal Popelin qui était
député Pest du nord de Paris, je crois.
Et dans son rapport euh le son rapport
c'est devenu comment adapter la liberté
d'expression et le droit de manifester
au maintien de l'ordre. Donc, j'ai été
le seul avec Marie-Gorge Buffet, le seul
des 30 commissaires à voter contre ce
rapport. Mais quand vous lisez bien ce
rapport, vous y voyez déjà le changement
de doctrine du maintien de l'ordre dans
ce pays. Et si le maintien de l'ordre
est devenu de plus en plus brutal et et
[grognement] comment dire ne
correspondant plus à ce qui était la
doctrine de la mise à distance et de et
et de la de la volonté de la
désescalade, et bien c'est à partir de
ce rapport là. Donc voyez que il faut
aller quelquefois fouiller dans les
archives pour comprendre d'où cela vient
et ne pas attribuer toujours les mêmes
responsabilité à ceux qu'on voit pour
l'instant parce qu'avant eux, il y a eu
un certain nombre de de politiques qui
ont qui ont une responsabilité et qui
ont conduit vers la situation dans
laquelle on se trouve. Donc pour
répondre à votre question, oui, il y a
en effet un chemin qui devient de plus
en plus chaotique et de plus en plus
dangereux qui peut nous conduire.
à des situations d'une de de à une
société qui en tout cas aura euh non pas
renoncer Oui. qui aura renoncé à
l'essentiel, c'est-à-dire la garantie de
nos libertés, la mise aujourd'hui on est
dans un pays dans lequel le préfet, le
policier et le procureur précèdent le
juge.
Or le juge Or le juge c'est celui qui
garantit nos libertés. Non mais le le
journaliste le journaliste il est pas
c'est pas lui qui est il est pas préfet,
il est pas policier, il est pas
procureur.
C'est lui qui est sous le robinet du
policier.
Bah c'est lui qui est sous le robinet.
C'est ben le journaliste, bien souvent,
il ne fait que contribuer à à renforcer,
disons à cautionner ce nouvel état des
choses, ce nouvel ordre juridique.
Mais il mais il y a aussi des
journalistes, il y a aussi des
journalistes qui se battent contre ça.
Euh je me souviens très bien que ben
écoutez, il y a quand même qu'on leur a
donné, c'est les moines. Il en reste
encore mais ils sont pas nombreux.
Il oui, ils sont pas nombreux. Par
exemple, quand on a fait avec Reporter
de RV Kempf, on avait fait à l'époque
une enquête avec ces journalistes qui
étit disséminé à Nant, à Paris, euh je
sais plus dans quelle autre ville pour
faire le bilan des
violences policières. Et nous avons fait
une conférence de presse avec Amnestie
Internationale avec le syndicat des
journalistes, syndicat national des
journalistes SNJ à l'Assemblée nationale
sur cette enquête qui montrait à
l'évidence les problèmes rencontrés.
D'ailleurs, on n'a pas servi à rien hein
puisque le défenseur des droits,
monsieur Toubon, à l'époque, a accepté
la saisine avec pour Amir Schrai. Nous
avons saisi le défenseur des droits sur
cette question des violences policières
à partir de l'enquête que nous avions
mené avec Reporter, c'est le le
défenseur des droits a accepté cette
saisine et et dans son rapport a proposé
la la l'interdiction de de la LBD. C'est
quoi la charte de Munique
là ? Pardon ?
La charte de Munich.
La charte Dominique
de Munique comme la ville.
Ah la charte de Munique. Je ne sais pas
pourquoi vous posez cette question.
Juste comme ça.
J'ai une question d'internet.
Non non mais éclirez-moi. C'est quoi la
charte de Munique ?
Oh c'est un c'est c'est un peu comme le
serment d'Hippocrate mais chez les
journalistes.
Je le connaissais pas mais de toute
façon il y a pas de je je pense qu'un
code de déontologie des journalistes
c'est c'est ce qu'il y aurait de pire.
Pourquoi ?
parce que euh le journalisme ne peut pas
être codifié de cette manière comme on
par exemple on va codifier la médecine
d'abord parce que c'est pas une science
exacte, pas plus que la médecine et que
ça doit être la responsabilité des
sociétés de journalistes. Oui, qu'il y
ait des sociétés de journalistes qui a
plus de pouvoir au sein des rédactions
et puis le problème des journalistes pe
avoir le meilleur code de déontologie du
monde. Si vous êtes dépendant de grands
groupes, comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui,
votre votre code de déontologie, vous
voyez ce que je veux dire.
[grognement]
D'ailleurs, c'est pas pour rien que leur
le
reniment ou le la conversion ou le
changement de Takedine dans quel journal
il a été il s'est fait dans Paris Match.
À qui appartient Paris Match ? À la
Gardè qui est membre du conseil
d'administration de la Gardè Sarkozy.
Ça n'engage que vous. [grognement]
Attention hein.
Non mais je pourrais vous donner plein
d'autres exemples.
Bon question d'internet. Je prends la
première qui me passe sous les yeux.
Ça ne veut pas dire que je pense que
Sargozi est responsable dans cette
histoire. C'est pas à moi de le dire
hein. Donc
c'est la justice.
Bonjour. Comme on parle de fake news
virgule Noël ma mère en 2013 a accusé
l'ex-président mauritanien Azis
d'être le parrain de la drogue.
Oui, c'est vrai. Oui. Dans l'émission 28
minutes en effet.
Euh il a il a voulu me faire un procès.
Alors en effet, c'était je pense que ce
que j'ai dit n'était pas faux mais et
que je n'avais
c'était peut-être pas vrai.
Je pense que c'était vrai parce que
j'avais des témoignages qui me le
disaient mais je ne pouvais pas en
apporter la preuve.
Donc c'est fa
donc je ne suis pas allé jusqu'au bout.
Non, c'est pas parce que vous ne pouvez
pas apporter la preuve de quelque chose.
Il y a des il y a eu des je sais pas
s'il y a des crimes parfaits, mais il y
a des il y a [grognement] il y a des des
épisodes judiciaires qui montrent que
quand vous pouvez pas administrer la
preuve, c'est c'est le bénéfice du
doute. Vous êtes Bah oui. Et donc je
j'ai renoncé à poursuivre mon d'abord
c'était lui qui m'avait attaqué en
justice. J'ai j'ai renoncé parce que je
ne j'étais pas en mesure d'apporter des
preuves suffisantes.
Euh je ne sais pas quel est le follower
qui suit ça et s'il suit ce qui se passe
du côté de la Mauritanie et de la zone
sub-saharienne, il sait très bien que
dans cette zone-là euh le la question de
la du trafic enf de la drogue n'est pas
n'est pas loin.
Alors question qui fâche, je la lis. Hm.
Euh euh qu'est-ce que ça a donné ? La
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique a annoncé mercredi soir
saisi la justice de dès la déclaration
de patrimoine de fin de mandat de
l'ex-député écologiste de Giron Noël ma
vu un doute sérieux lié à l'omission
d'une partie substantielle du
patrimoine. Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Alors bah c'est un truc assez assez
idiot.
C'est la maison de Mémé qui a pas été
déclarée.
Non non non non. D'abord euh alors c'est
une un truc totalement idiot. Ça s'est
passé, c'était ma déclaration, la
dernière déclaration que je devais
faire, la première déclaration que j'ai
faite, la la loi sur la haute autorité.
La haute autorité a été créée en 2013.
Donc la il a été demandé aux députés de
faire une déclaration d'intérêt et de
patrimoine en 2014,
hein. C'était un an après, ce qui était
tout à fait normal. Et après c'est la
loi voulait que lorsque vous terminez
votre mandat, vous devez refaire une
déclaration de patrimoine pour savoir si
votre patrimoine a évolué de manière
normale ou si il s'est passé des choses.
Présellement si vous en êtes mis plein
les fouilles.
Non non pas du tout. Je m'en suis pas du
tout mis plein les fouilles. C'est pas
du tout ça. Résumer résumé. Non, j'ai
j'ai tout simplement comme j'étais tout
seul parce que le tout simplement le le
père de mon épouse venait de mettre fin
à ses jours, elle n'était pas là et
c'est elle qui depuis que on est marié
depuis 30 ans fait les déclarations
d'impôts. J'ai oublié tout simplement de
déclarer ces euh ces
Allons euh
c'est c'est pas les assurances, comment
on appelle ça ? Mince, le
je devrais le dire de
comment ça s'appelle ? Pension de
reversion.
Non non non, c'est pas les pensions de
reversion. Euh
c'est pas Excusez-moi, j'ai j'ai un
trou.
Assurances vies.
C'est assurance vie. Voilà. Donc j'ai
j'ai oublié ces assurances vies. Donc
c'est une omission. Cette omission, elle
a été sanctionnée, ce qui est tout à
fait normal. Mais cette omission a été,
pour que les choses soient bien claires
entre nous, cette omission des
assurances vies a été indiquée à la
Haute Autorité par l'administration des
finances, ce qui veut dire que elles ont
été toutes déclarées. Donc je n'ai
aucune je n'ai aucun problème avec
l'administration fiscale puisque c'est
l'administration fiscale qui a dit à
l'aute autorité "Mais attendez, il y a
il y a il y a il y a telle et telle
assurance vie, pardonnez-moi."
Avez tu en avais pour combien ?
Comment
il y en avait pour combien ? Vous
n'alvez pas le savoir parce que je c'est
mon c'est c'est notre affaire. Euh mais
en effet euh j'ai j'ai été condamné,
enfin condamné, j'ai j'éta sanctionné
pour cette omission, ce qui est tout à
fait euh tout à fait normal, mais je
n'ai volé d'argent à personne euh
puisque ça a été euh déclaré à
l'administration felle.
Vous n'avez pas reçu le pot de vin.
Pourquoi j'aurais reçu des pots de vin ?
Mais non, mais c'est la question c'est
sur non, ça n'a rien à voir mais la
transparence c'est celle-ci, c'est que
j'étais transparent totalement puisque
l'administration fiscale c'est elle qui
a dit à la haute autorité que j'avais
omis les assurances vie. Pardonnez-moi
pour les le temps que j'ai mis à trouver
assurance vie, mais c'est ça exactement
ce qui s'est passé.
Un journaliste qui devient politique,
c'est un petit peu comme un infiltré.
Est-ce que Non, est-ce que vous avez vu
un journaliste qui devient politique ?
Il y en a pas beaucoup. Il y en a eu
quelques-uns. Pericard, était-il déjà
politique quand il présentait les
journaux ? Je ne sais pas. Euh, il y a
eu mon mon collègue qui est mort
prématurément, le maire de Toulouse. Euh
puis je viens le retrouver. Euh il y a
on est assez peu nombreux en fait, je
sais pas, on est peut-être 5 ou six à
avoir été Dominique
Baudis euh qui était le successeur de
son père à la mairie de Toulouse.
Pardonnez-moi, c'est la vieillesse sans
doute qui commence à creuser dans mon
cerveau. Euh et donc oui, on n'est pas
très nombreux. Non non, c'est pas du
tout c'est un choix délibéré. Donc
j'avais le sentiment d'avoir fait le
tour de ce que je voulais faire à la
télévision. Euh en fait, j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance parce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait que des émissions engagées.
Les 5 c'est la vie, c'était une émission
engagée sur l'environnement puisque
notre notre objet c'était de dénoncer
les failles, [grognement] de dénoncer
tout ce qui pouvait être toutes les
toutes les atteintes à l'environnement.
Euh j'ai eu une parenthèse qui est tout
à fait et que j'ai que j'ai adoré qui
était celle du trésor. Vous vous imposez
une obligation de réserve par rapport à
vos à vos engagements, ce qui est tout à
fait normal par respect pour les
spectateurs. Et puis après, les cinq
autres années de résistance, c'est une
émission qui était une émission
militante sur les droits de l'homme.
Donc j'ai quand même eu j'ai j'ai eu
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance. J'ai j'ai eu
une grande liberté en fait dans mon dans
l'exercice de mon métier parce que pour
vous donner un exemple, c'est la vie.
Euh c'était tous les soirs à 18h30. Je
participais à la conférence de rédaction
le matin euh qui était la conférence de
rédaction qui est préparé le 20h et
j'arrivais au bout au bout de la
consultation du REDAC chef. Il y avait
la politique étrangère, service société,
service culture et toi Noël qu'est-ce
que tu as ? Je disais vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien. Donc jamais personne m'a
emmerdaé. Mon ami Céillon disait de
toute façon Noël il fait de
l'information au rat de la toile cirée
parce que à l'époque si vous voulez la
noblesse du journalisme c'était d'aller
faire du grand reportage sur du grand
reportage de guerre et le journalisme
que je pratiquais c'était-à-dire du
journalisme à de la porte d'à côté de
proximité ça n'avait pas encore de
c'est c'était c'était méprisé d'une
certaine manière et le fait que ce soit
méprisé par une grande partie des
journalistes m'a permis une très grande
une très grande liberté après
coup
oui
Je peux vous couper avec une question un
peu vulgaire.
Allez-y.
Est-ce que vous trouvez pas que les
présentateur de télé aussi appelés
journalistes
léchent pas un peu trop le cul des
politiques quand ils leur font leurs
interviews ? Est-ce que est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous imaginez pas ce petit
fil de bave ? Vous voyez en ce côté un
peu en adoration devant leurs idoles ?
Oui, il y a toujours eu euh de la part
des de beaucoup de journalistes d'une on
va dire oui d'une majorité de
journalistes qui se qui sont choisis
pour cet exercice parce qu'ils sont pas
très nombreux
parce qu'ils ont pas de réflexe de
déglition. C'est ça.
Non, c'est pas ça. C'est que il y a
cette espèce de fascination euh de
fascination pour le pour le pouvoir.
Euh comment le dire autrement ? Euh nous
n'avons pas cette culture dans le
journalisme français. Nous n'avons pas
cette culture dans le journalisme
français qui est celle des des pays
anglo-saxons.
Quand vous regardez par exemple la l'une
des dernières interviews de Fox News qui
était considéré comme l'ami de Trump, de
cette grande représentatrice vedette de
Fox News, elle a été sans concession
avec Trump alors qu'on aurait pu
imaginer qu'elle soit très docile et
qu'elle ne pose pas de questions qui
dérangent. Oui, c'est vrai que
euh l'histoire montre que dans ce pays,
c'est sans doute l'héritage de du poids
du gaulisme pendant plusieurs décennies
sur la télé qui a qui a laissé des
traces. Oui, je pense que c'est ça tra
et de toute façon les traces de ça qui
sont des traces politiques, elles ont
été remplacées par des dépendances
économiques.
Donc, j'allais dire, on est à peu près
dans la même situation. Il y a il y a
très peu de il y a très peu
d'interviewers
qui sont capables de de d'aller d'aller
un peu plus loin que le convenu.
C'est ça. Oui.
Comment on fait pour
changer et améliorer tout ça ? Là, on
sent bien que le pays part un petit peu
à volot. On a une class qui est en
panique, qui navigue à vue, une
administration qui se rend compte
qu'elle doit un petit peu plus
travailler, qu'elle doit être un petit
peu plus secouée, surtout quand il y a
des des événements exotiques délétaire.
On sent bien que la résilience de notre
administration était l'équivalente d'un
gamin de 4 ans face à son caca dans la
main.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour arranger ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ben ce qu'on fait
c'est que en effet
c'est ce c'est la question de la
démocratisation euh de la société. C'est
comment éviter euh que cette société ne
fasse que reproduire un certain nombre
de de schémas qui sont le schéma euh
néolibéral. Oui, même peut-être empire.
Euh c'est par exemple quand vous dites
la upper classe. Bon ben ça pose la
question euh ça pose la question du
consentement à l'impôt, ça pose la
question de la redistribution, euh ça
pose la question de la solidarité, ça
pose la question de service public.
C'est quoi un service public ? de
l'accès de tous à ces services publics,
que ce soit le service public de la
connaissance et de l'éducation, que ce
soit le service public de la culture,
que soit le service public de la santé
et comment on réintroduit dans la
société ceux qui aujourd'hui en sont
d'une certaine manière à la périphérie,
ceux qui n'ont pas eu la chance de
réussir entre guillemets et je pense que
c'est sur cet axe là qu'il faut
qu'il faut revoir nos sociétés. Et donc
la la question des inégalités est la
question qui prime. On ne peut pas
parler d'écologie sans l'adoser à la
question des inégalités, à la question
de la démocratie. Comment un associe ?
Comment on comment vous dire ? On vit
dans des sociétés en silo. En fait, ce
que vous venez de dire c'est ça, c'est
que chacun est dans son chacun est dans
son silo et ces silos se parlent de
moins en moins. Communique de moins en
moins entre eux. Pourquoi ils communique
de moins en moins entre eux ? Parce que
face à la vulnérabilité du monde et à
l'incertitude dont je parlais au début
de cet entretien
et chaque silo a tendance à se refermer
sur lui-même. Et puis quand vous prenez
les réseaux sociaux, Facebook, c'est la
même chose hein, c'est chacun qui qui
parle qui qui se conforte dans sa même
idée. Donc au lieu qu'il y ait des
passerelles entre ces différentes
catégories, aujourd'hui il y a des murs
qui se construisent. C'est la question
du commun. Qu'est-ce qui nous est commun
? Et comment fait-on pour que ce commun
devienne la règle et qu'il concerne
l'ensemble de de la société ? Vous voyez
ce comprenez ce que je veux dire ? Nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans des sociétés qui
ont oublié la question des communs, la
question de ce qui nous est commun parce
que elles se sont enfoncées dans des
formes d'égoïsme qui sont pas simplement
des égoïsmes nationaux mais des égoïsmes
internationaux qui font que chacun va
essayer de de se défendre de défendre ce
qui peut lui assurer sa survie. Mais
c'est pas pour rien d'ailleurs
qu'aujourd'hui face aux menaces que fait
peser le réchauffement climatique sur
nos sociétés, il y est un mouvement
qu'on appelle le survivalisme. Le
survivalisme, ce sont principalement des
ultra riches
pour beaucoup venus d'ailleurs de la
Silicone Vallée qui vont aller investir
qui investissent en Nouvelle-Zélande au
point que la Nouvelle-Zélande a fait
voter des lois pour limiter le les
achats de de terre dans son pays. Ce
sont d'autres qui vont construire des
bunnkers et s'armer éviter de tomber
avec les autres. Mais sauf que c'est pas
comme le Titanic hein, le réchauffement
climatique. Il y aura pas la peut-être
que la première classe disparaîtra un
petit peu après la 2e et la 3è classe
mais son destin, il est déjà il est déjà
écrit. Donc il faut aller chercher les
les ferments du commun dans ces petits
lieux
que sont les lieux les écolieux et les
lieux alternatifs comme Notre Dame des
Landes par exemple. Et dans toutes les
initiatives qui sont prises dans la
société, il y a pas besoin d'aller dans
des écolieux.
Comment on fait pour
pour que le commun pour que le commun
prospère ? Comment on fait pour
pardonnez-moi ?
Alors, comment on fait pour que le
commun prospère alors que vous avez des
factions
h
à gauche, à droite, au centre qui
pratiquent la pureté idéologique
et qui refusent de tendre la main pour
s'entendre sur un une route commune.
Comment on fait ? L'extrême droite le
fait, l'extrême gauche le fait, ils le
font tous. Et on se retrouve avec des
minorités très agressive pratiquant
l'idéologie la plus pure pour eux.
Oui. Alors tout ce ils peuvent mourir
guéris mais ils mourront.
Ils mourront de leur pureté. d'abord
comme vous l'avez dit sont minoritaires.
Donc je pense que quand une société se
mobilise de manière massive, ces
minorités sont appelé à rester
minoritaires et et même à être
complètement dépassé. Il y aura toujours
dans nos sociétés, il y aura toujours
des des minorités qui chercheront la
pureté idéologique et qui au nom de
cette pureté sont capables d'aller de
faire terre les autres. Non, mais qui
sont capables d'aller jusqu'à tuer.
Enfin, il y a beaucoup d'analystes qui
sont aujourd'hui développées sur ces ces
fameux et tristes et sinistres
islamistes qui sont capables d'aller
couper la tête des gens. Mais
il y a pas de fatalité dans une société.
Il y a pas de fatalité à ce qu'elle soit
débordée par ses minorités. tout ce qui
est toutes les toutes les idéologies qui
ont défendu euh la pureté, qui ont voulu
la faire appliquer contre les libertés,
contre la vie, elles ont échoué. Ça a
duré longtemps pour certaines. Le
totalitarisme soviétique a duré
longtemps.
Il y a eu l'épisode tragique de la choa
au nom de de la pureté de de la race,
mais fort heureusement les sociétés ont
été capables de se de se réveiller ou en
tout cas de de réagir et de se
mobiliser. Donc je pense que même si le
déni est prime aujourd'hui dans les dans
les dans l'ensemble du monde, il n'y a
pas de fatalité à ce que nous restions
dans le déni. D'abord parce qu'il y a
des gens
il y a pas de fatalité à ce qu'on reste
dans le déni. C'est ce que vous venez de
dire.
Oui. Oui. Il y a pas de fatalité à ce
qu'on reste dans le déni parce que
[soupir]
comment vous dire ? Moi, j'ai si je me
suis engagé dans la vie politique
pendant 25 ans ou 28 ans, c'est bien
parce que j'avais plus de raisons
d'espérer que de désespérer. Quand vous
vous engager dans la vie politique,
c'est pas simplement contrairement à ce
que croient beaucoup de gens pour dire
"On va gagner du fric, j'ai gagné plus
de fric à la télé que dans mon mé de
combien. Combien vous gagnez ?"
Bah quand j'étais député le je crois que
l'indemnité d'un député
euh les toute charges comp ça tourne
autour de 5000 € à peu près.
Voilà. Donc euh oh ben dans la télé
c'est beaucoup plus enfin je sais pas
combien mais je ne sais pas combien mais
c'est beaucoup plus enfin
c'est quoi allez c'est quoi les salaire
mais je ne les connais pas les salaires
de la télé quand je suis parti de la
télé il y avait pas encore les euros je
gagnais 26000 balles
net
ouais
mais attendez après je suis parti je
suis parti en bah oui je suis parti en
92 26000 francs
mais je peux vous dire que quand je suis
parti déjà il y avait eu il y avait eu
Berlusc con à la 5 et que le le le PAF
était en train d'exploser avec des
salaires avec des des salaires
incroyable attribué à des à des
animateurs pour venir faire les beaux
jours de la chaîne. Donc c'était c'était
très loin de cette de cette somme là et
aujourd'hui des présentateurs de
journaux les animateurs, ils gagnent
bien plus que ça. Oui.
Puadas Pujadas,
je ne sais pas combien il gagnent, je
peux pas vous dire.
Allez petite fourchette. [rires]
Non, je ne sais pas. 10 15 30
Non, je pense que c'est plutôt de des
c'est plutôt ça tourne plutôt entre 10
et 15000 € sans doute
net. Je ne sais pas si c'est net ou pas.
Je suis pas je suis pas fonctionnaire de
question question d'internet
d'administration fiscale.
Question d'internet que je vais essayer
de de synthétiser. Comment on fait pour
qu'il y ait plus de journalistes qui
deviennent porte-parole de politique ?
Mais je vois pas pourquoi. Il faudrait
que le follower précise sa question.
Est-ce qu'il parle de journalistes qui
sont en fonction de journalistes dans
une dans un média ?
Bernard Getta, eurodéputé LREM et B
Roger Petit devenu
mais Bernard Getta, il est plus
journaliste. Bernard Getta, il a été
journaliste. Donc il n'est le porte il
est le porte-parole de son de son groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale. Mais vous allez
pas lui reprocher d'avoir été
journaliste. Il a été journaliste.
Alors reprocher d'être porte-parole d'un
politique derrière.
Et pourquoi il peut et pourquoi on
pourrait le reprocher ? Mais attendez
journaliste c'est pas une journaliste,
c'est pas c'est pas une autre caméra,
vous faites plusieurs métiers. Est-ce
que je vous
C'est pas une profession qui doit être
sacralisée. Je
pas du tout, pas du tout. Pierre
Salinger a été le porte-parole
Est-ce que le journaliste
Pierre Salinger a été le porte-parole de
John Fidal Kennedy et ensuite le
correspondant pour toute l'Europe de la
chaîne IBC. Est-ce que ça l'a empêché de
faire son métier de journaliste ?
Réponse : Non. Les hommes sont capables.
On peut être journaliste, on est dans un
pays où on voudrait nous mettre dans des
cases. Alors, vous avez été journaliste,
ben vous resterez journaliste toute
votre vie. Vous pourriez rien faire
d'autre. Bah non. Non, c'est pas parce
que j'ai été journaliste que j'ai pas pu
m'engager dans la vie politique. Et
d'ailleurs, le fait queon me voyait tous
les soirs à la télé a été pour moi au
début un handicap parce que les gens,
ils étaient contents de voir la star
entre guillemets qui sortait de son
petit écran et il voulait le toucher
comme si j'étais un roi tomaturge. Je
leur disais non, je suis pas venu sortir
de mon écran pour vous faire plaisir.
Oui, je suis venu pour essayer de vous
convaincre pour essayer de de défendre
les idées auxquelles je crois devant
vous. Non non, je pense que Geta, bah il
a fait un choix. Voilà. Et maintenant,
bah maintenant GTA il n'est plus
journaliste, il est politique.
Est-ce que un politique peut redevenir
journaliste ?
Et moi par exemple, je pourrais jamais
revenir dans un journal, je le sais très
bien. Voilà, c'est comme ça.
Pourquoi ? À moins d'être éditorialiste
dans un journal engagé qui euh je
pourrais par exemple, je sais pas euh
faire des chroniques, ce qui m'est
arrivé d'ailleurs, j'avais un blog dans
Reporter était et je suis membre du
conseil d'administration de Bastamag
mais j'y écris pas mais je me vestis
mais c'est pas voilà c'est mon c'est ce
sont des journaux engagés sont pas vous
me voyez pas revenir présenter une
émission à France 2.
Non
et ça ne m'empêche pas de proposer des
documentaires, mais c'est j'ai le droit
d'avoir un regard sur le monde et de
et et de le faire partager à travers des
des documentaires.
Question internet. Avez-vous déjà
participé au dîner du siècle ? Si oui,
quelles ont été vos observations ?
Jamais. Jamais. Je n'ai jamais été
invité. Je fais pas partie de ce monde
là.
C'est quoi ce monde là ? Bah écoutez,
c'est un monde je connais pas mal de
gens qui étaient au dîner du siècle mais
je ne fonctionne pas chez des gens avec
qui j'ai entretenu des relations que je
connais que j'ai croisé mais c'est pas
mon monde. Voilà donc je n'étais pas
convié au dîner du siècle et je pense
que ceux qui l'organisaient et les
responsables du dîner du siècle ne m'y
voyaient pas.
Ça tombe bien, je m'y voyais pas non
plus.
Pourquoi ? parce que je vous dis c'est
pas bon mon monde. C'est c'est ça
correspond à ce à ce que vous disiez au
milieu de notre entretien. C'est euh
c'est une manière de c'est c'est c'est
ces scénacles, c'est ces cercles qui
deviennent des scénacles. Enfin, on
appelle ça des cercles d'ailleurs, hein.
Ça s'appelait comme ça en tout cas. Bah,
ce sont des cercles où on on reste entre
soi. C'est de l'entre soi. On cultive
cet entre soi pour se sentir très bien
entre nous. Voilà, il y a eux puis il y
a nous ou il y a nous et il y a eux.
C'est pas mon truc.
Les journalistes, ils doivent être sur
ce type de cercle ou pas ?
Non, je crois pas. Je crois qu'un
journaliste qui euh vous savez le le
siècle ça
fait partie de ces cercles qui sont qui
sont la marque de votre reconnaissance
sociale et de votre réussite sociale.
Donc c'est pas c'est pas du tout
étonnant qu'on voit des journalistes
très heureux de faire partie de du
siècle parce que c'est une manière c'est
une manière pour eux d'être reconnu dans
leur dans leur statut de devenir de
faire partie de l'élite pour reprendre
une expression qu'on a utilisé pendant
cet entretien
mais moi je ne m'y vois pas et je pense
que les que les journalistes ne
devraient pas participer à ce genre de
de cercle.
Vous avez quel souvenir de votre école
de journaliste ? Je n'ai jamais fait
d'école de journalisme. J'ai fait j'ai
fait une licence qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui une maîtrise de droit, un
diplôme de sciences politiques, tout ça
à Bordeaux. J'ai [grognement] je suis
titulaire d'une thèse de 3e cycle en
science de l'information et de la
communication. Mais mon métier, je l'ai
appris sur le tas comme on dit car en
sortant de première année de droit en
1969,
donc tout ceux qui vous suivent
n'étaient pas nés. Euh
c'est pas vrai, on a des gens de votre
âge qui su très bien. Alors tant mieux.
Salut
et même plus vieux.
Alors bienvenue au club. Euh oui, en
sortant de première année de droit, je
suis devenu journaliste à l'ORTF, ça
s'appelait encore, à Bordeaux où je
faisais de la radio et de la télé, des
reportages télé. et j'ai présenté mon
premier JT à 20 ans euh à l'Fordeaux.
Donc, j'y allais pratiquement tous les
soirs pour faire des commentaires des
journaux télévisés euh et pour faire la
radio euh pendant l'année universitaire
et puis pendant les vacances
universitaires. Pour moi, c'était pas du
tout euh une charge, c'était au
contraire un plaisir. en je je faisais
le journaliste
qui qui faisait des reportages et puis
j'ai en sortant de en sortant de
sciences pot en 74
j'ai été assistant associé à à l'IUT de
journalisme qui s'appelle LIBA
aujourd'hui qui était une qui est une
école qui était une des trois écoles de
journalisme reconnu par la convention
collective des journalistes avec Lî et
Strasbourg. Euh j'y ai j'ai enseigné à
la radio et la télé aux étudiants
pendant 3 ans. Voilà. Et après je suis
entré Antenne 2,
mais je n'ai pas fait d'école du
journalisme.
De deux petites questions qui continuent
dans le dans le même sens de Dick. Vous
connaissez Dick ? C'est un très bon
film, on vous le conseille.
Non.
Quit de la conivance des journalistes et
des politiques qui sortent souvent des
mêmes écoles issues des mêmes couches
sociales. Point interrogation. Oui, moi
ça a été alors il faut dire à ce
followers, je sais pas à quel âge il a
ça doit être du 26 27 ans.
Alors s'il a 26 27 ans,
euh je vais pas lui recommander de se
précipiter dans une librairie parce
qu'en ce moment c'est pas possible, mais
qu'il fasse un click and connect et
qu'il se procure un livre majeur d'un
sociologue américain des années 50 qui
s'appelle Charles Wills. Et Charles
Whtmills, c'est le sociologue qui a
écrit sur les élites. Les élites parlent
aux élites et comment ces élites sont
formées dans les mêmes moules et comment
ça se comment ils se reproduisent. Vousz
lu ce fameux livre propaganda ? Oui,
bien sûr, mais j'ai surtout lu le livre
de Jacques Elule euh qui s'appelle
Propagande au pluriel et qui est euh qui
qu'il faut absolument lire pour
détricoter les méthodes de propagande de
l'extrême gauche comme de l'extrême
droite ou de la droite comme de la
gauche. lui il a il a écrit ce livre en
pratiquant une étude très fouillée
[grognement] notamment sur la technique
puisque c'était sa spécialité sur les
techniques de propagande des nazis et
les techniques de propagande des des
staliniennes et vous verrez qu'il y a
beaucoup de ressemblances.
Question d'internet : peut-on jouer
honnêtement à un jeu avec que des
tricheurs ? Si oui, comment ? Bah
jouer qu'avec des tricheurs, c'est quand
même assez dur. Mais moi, contrairement
à ce que dit ce follower, je ne pense
pas qu'il y a que des tricheurs. Qui
a rajouté que lui sa question c'était
peut-on jouer honnêtement à un jeu avec
des tricheurs ?
Ça dépend combien il y a tricheurs dans
le jeu.
C'est un équilibre.
S'il y a quatre tricheurs et un qui
triche pas, c'est un petit peu
difficile. Mais les tricheurs s'annulent
à force de tricher. Donc ça peut
permettre à celui qui ne triche pas
d'émerger.
Ouais. Couler ou de couler le
capitalisme et nous envoyer par le fond
avec eux.
Oui, couler le capita. pensais que la
presse spécialisée h
la presse économique la presse
scientifique d'ailleurs récemment est-ce
que on l'a bien vu avec la crise de 2008
la presse économique était complètement
larguée depuis des années et il ne
faisait que de sculpter de l'air chaud
et de brasser de la fumée à grand coup
de on sait tout, vous inquiétez pas, on
est sur des rails. Est-ce que la presse
scientifique s'est fait démasquer comme
la presse économique en 2008,
c'est-à-dire ça ne brasse que du vent,
ça occupe qu'une seule chaise, ça fait
chauffer un petit peu le le le faux cuir
de son de sa chaise de bureau. Ça écrit
de temps en temps des petits papiers,
mais quand réellement le carton arrive,
ils sont complètement perdus et ils
embrayent sous le robinet de
l'information politique.
Oui. C'est il faut aller plus loin que
ce que vous dites
parce que là je vais pas faire le savant
mais franchement s'il y a un bouquin à
lire en ce moment sur la les connexions
entre les publications y compris
d'ailleurs des publications
scientifiques euh je sais plus je sais
pas si le land 7 en fait partie mais des
publications scientifiques et la presse
dite scientifique et même le journalisme
scientifique
qui est en fait en en en liaison avec
beaucoup de de grands lobby industriels
ou pharmaceutiques.
Il faut lire le livre de Stéphane
Fouard,
de Stéphan Fouard, Stéphane Essel et je
vais retrouver le nom du sociologue qui
l'a fait avec eux qui est sorti il y a 2
mois aux éditions la découverte qui
s'appelle Les gardiens de la raison.
Bon, il faut savoir que Stéphane Fouard
et Stéphane Essel sont les journalistes
qui sont responsables de la page planète
dans le monde et qui sont euh comment
dire des journalistes d'investigation.
C'est eux qui euh avaient sorti euh les
Monsanto Paper. Et donc leur livre est
est j'allais dire, je sais pas si on
peut dire qu'il est effrayant, mais il
est très instructif parce qu'il démontre
comment vous avez un certain nombre de
journalistes. Moi je me souviens que il
y a pas très longtemps dans une émission
de LCP, je me suis fait démonter par une
journaliste qui est journaliste au point
que l'on voit régulièrement sur BFM TV
et dont je ne citerai pas le nom qui m'a
qui m'a sorti le brévière du de Laurent
Alexandre, le brévière du promor
ridoré pro nucléaire en disant enfin
mais on a le droit d'être pro nucléaire
hein. Mais mais je suis d'accord mais si
vous voulez avec
vous préférez être prucléire prucléire
ou pro central à charbon je ne suis ni
pro nuucléaire ni pro central à charbon
je suis proe efficacité énergétique pro
énergie renouvelable et pro et pro
économie d'énergie et j'ai surtout
contre l'oléodépendance
et donc par exemple que des sociétés des
banques comme la BNP et d'autres quand
elles investissent 7 € dans les énergies
fossiles elles investissent 1 € dans les
énergies renouvelables. Donc il faut
arrêter de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles. Mais là encore, Bastamag a un
comment dire une branche qui s'appelle
l'observatoire des multinationales qui
raconte ça très bien et qui le démontre
très bien et qui démontre très bien
quelle est aujourd'hui la l'hypocrisie
du gouvernement et et de toutes ces
sociétés qui font qui font du green
washing. Donc en effet, il y a
aujourd'hui ces gardiens de la raison
ont réussi
à enfin c'est c'est comme le le film qui
avait eu beaucoup de succès des nouveaux
chiens de garde de de Serge Alimi. C'est
c'est à peu près pareil. Aujourd'hui, il
y a des nouveaux chiens de garde. C'est
ces chiens de garde, c'est c'est les
chiens de garde qui par exemple comme
nos philosophes médiatiques patentés qui
s'attaquent à la figure de Greta
Tenberg, y compris d'ailleurs en mettant
en avant son notice Asperger. Enfin,
c'est vraiment des attaques adominem si
si je puis dire parlant d'hystérie là
même et ça se reproduit hein. C'est ce
que vous raconte très bien le livre de
Stéphane Essel et Stéphane Fouer quand
Rachel Carson en 1962 a écrit le
printemps silencieux qui a été à
l'origine du mouvement écolo aux
États-Unis qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
sur le DDT, elle était traitée
d'hystérique.
Bon bah 50 ans plus tard ou 60 ans plus
tard, Gretaberg est traité d'hystérique
par les mêmes. Ce sont ces chiens de
garde qui ne veulent surtout pas voir
changer les choses, qui sont pour le
statut quo et qui sont en fait les
alliés objectifs, les idiots utiles de
ces grands lobby qui eux veulent
satisfaire leurs intérêts à court terme
et qui sont en train de comment dire de
de brouiller qui qui ont réussi en fait
à à faire bifurquer l'information
scientifique vers de la propagande.
Alors, revenons à l'information
scientifique et au journalistes
scientifiques.
Là, avec la crise du Covid, on voit
émerger les antimasques, les antivaccins
et ainsi de suite qui se servent
de des mensonges de notre gouvernement
et des mensonges relayés par les
journalistes scientifiques pour fiouler,
pour euh mettre de l'énergie à leur
discours de vous voyez bien, ça sert à
rien de porter des masques, vous on vous
raconte n'importe quoi, c'est le nouvel
ordre mondial, on veut on veut eutaniser
tous les pauvres et je vous en passe et
les meilleurs.
le yaourt concentré de tout un tas de
bêtises. On fait quoi ? On s'attaque à
madame Michu
qui quand même se rend compte que ce
qu'on lui a raconté à la télé, c'est
parce qu'elle vit dans la vraie vie.
Queun con lui dit le masque, tu
comprends, faut pas le mettre. Bon,
maintenant, tu comprends, faut le
mettre. Sinon, c'est 135 €. Est-ce que
qui est responsable ? Et madame Michu,
c'est le compte journaliste qui n'y
connaît strictement rien, qui a été
formé à l'arrache, qui prend ses 2000
balles par mois avec sa niche fiscale et
qui est très content de réciter sa
petite sa petite,
on va dire prière religieuse qu'on lui a
demandé d'apprendre ou c'est le
politique qui était en panique, qui a
essayé de gérer comme il pouvait. C'est
qui ? C'est tout ce biotop ? C'est le
journaliste qui est à la rue, le
politique qui est à la rue ou madame
Michu qui est à la rue ? Bah c'est
j'allais dire c'est
un système éducatif qui n'appassion
madame c'est ni l'un ni l'autre et
l'autre c'est sans doute un ensemble.
D'abord c'est certainement pas la faute
de madame Michu. Euh le comportement de
madame Michu il n'est que la conséquence
d'un défaut d'explication.
Il n'est que la conséquence de mensonge
pour ce qui concerne par exemple les
masques au début du du premier
confinement.
et il est il est et le comportement de
madame Michu, il ne il ne se nourrit
justement de de toutes ces imperfections
et de toute cette comment dire, c'est
pas de l'opacité parce que c'est pas
exactement le mot parce que faire croire
que tout est opaque, c'est c'est une
manière de de contribuer au complotisme.
C'est un un défaut c'est un défaut
tragique d'une carence démocratique qui
fait qu'on ne s'attache pas à à
l'explicitation de la complexité du
monde
dans la bienveillance.
Non, la bienveillance ça veut rien dire.
J'aime pas ce mot. Le la bienveillance
c'est que vous soyez bienveillant avec
moi ou que je sois bienveillant avec
vous. C'est ça. La bienveillance c'est
pas ça. Et puis moi, je pense que c'est
pas la bienveillance qu'on doit mettre
en avant. C'est l'entraide. Ce qui est
autre chose qui a été très bien expliqué
par Reclu et Cropotkin. Euh et
l'entraide, ça implique la solidarité.
On ne pas être bienveillant. Je pas être
bienveillant avec celui qui est plus
petit que moi ou celui qui est moins
visible que moi. J'ai à être dans
l'entraide et dans la solidarité avec
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont les plus
pénalisés par le système dans lequel
dans lequel nous vivons. Et c'est
justement ces gens qui sont pénalisés
qui pensent que les autres, ceux qui les
nantis, ceux qui sont de pardon ceux qui
sont dedans ne font que ne font que
réfléchir, que penser, qu'être obsédé
par le fait qu'il faudrait que que
madame Michu, elle reste à l'écart. Bon
ben ça implique un renversement de la
pyramide démocratique. Oui, évidemment
qui est qui va qui est d'une très grande
verticalité et qui justement est aussi
malade. Et ça de ce point de vue
Macron il a beaucoup contribué qui est
malade de de la suppression de ses corps
intermédiaires. Regardez la faiblesse
des syndicats. regarder aujourd'hui avec
notamment tiens par exemple le la COVID
qui
touche beaucoup les associations que
soient des associations sportives ou des
associations d'éducation populaire qui
sont autant d'outils de socialisation
autant d'outils de la connaissance
autant d'outils de qui permettent de
faire des citoyens responsables et
debout alors là aujourd'hui c'est
l'ignorance qui prime. L'ignorance et la
peur de soi. Vous savez quand quand j'ai
marié deux hommes à Beigle le 5 juin
2004,
j'ai reçu 4000 lettres d'insultes.
J'ai reçu bah j'ai pas fait que des
trucs bien, mais celui-là oui, c'est la
seule trace qui restera d'ailleurs de
mon histoire politique. Mais euh
j'ai fait quand j'ai fait ça, c'était au
nom de l'égalité des droits. J'ai pas
pris cette initiative tout seul. C'est
parce queavant il y a eu un gars qui
s'appelle Sébastien Nouchet qui avait
été brûlé grièvement qui est dans une
chaise roulante aujourd'hui qui a
suscité la naissance de du manifeste
pour l'égalité des droits avec des gens
comme Didier Hribibon ou Caroline Mécari
et quelques autres et qui euh qui ont
demandé que dans ce manifeste pour
l'égalité des droits, il y avait le le
mariage pour les personnes de même sexe.
Donc ils avaient demandé à des élus euh
d'être associé de s'associer à ce
manifeste. ce que j'ai fait
et puis on a fait une conférence de
presse, je vous raconte l'histoire
brièvement, on a fait une conférence de
presse à Paris avec Clémentine Autin qui
était adjoint au maire, Christophe
Girard,
Jacques Boutau qui était maire du 2e
arrondissement merveilleux et ils ont
dit nous avons dit nous nous marirons,
on a la délégation, on mariera des
personnes de même sexe si elles nous le
demandent.
Et donc Bertrand de la Noé qui était le
maire, c'est le maire qui donne les
délégations a dit "Vous n'aurez pas la
délégation de mariage." Mais moi,
j'étais maire, donc j'étais j'étais le
maître de mon destin, si je puis dire.
Et donc j'étais à Paris à l'assemblée et
quand ma Marie m'a appelé en disant
"Voilà, il y a deux gars qui vous ont
entendu à la télé, il voulit se paxer
mais comme il vous a entendu, ils
veulent se marier, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
?" Ben, j'ai dit "On il est marié." Et
effectivement, j'ai pas choisi un avocat
et un journaliste du 4e arrondissement.
C'était deux deux hommes du bas de
l'échelle sociale. L'un était magasinier
et l'autre était au chômage.
Euh voilà. Et ça a été un épisode ça a
duré plus de d'un mois et demi. Ça a été
compliqué. 4000 lettres d'insulte. J'ai
même un médecin qui a signé 11 lettres
et qui sur la 11e lettre a dessiné un
four crématoire.
Ouais. Oui, oui, oui, je recevais des
lettres avec des traces d'étron et
d'ailleurs un sociologue qui s'appelle
Éric Fassin a fait travailler ses
étudiants sur euh sur ces lettres qui
ont été euh conservés évidemment. Et
quand on me disait "Mais alors c'est des
gens haineux" et je répondais souvent et
je réponds encore aujourd'hui
que tous ces gens-là n'était pas animé
par la haine mais par l'ignorance et la
peur de soi. Et s'il y a un trait
d'union entre le journalisme et la
politique, c'est précisément de lutter
contre la peur de soi et contre
l'ignorance. Et c'est comme ça que vous
faites des citoyens parandiens parce que
si vous avez peur de vous-même, vous
avez peur de l'autre. vous perdez
l'estime de vous-même. En perdant
l'estime de soi, vous avez la haine de
vous-même et donc forcément la haine de
l'autre. Et donc je pense que ce qui
animait ces gens-là, c'était cela. En
plus euh le l'homosexualité, la question
de l'homosexualité fait appel à à des
choses extrêmement intimes qui révèlent
d'ailleurs, c'est très étonnant, enfin
non, c'est pas étonnant en fait, mais
j'ai des copains très intelligents, très
cultivés,
qui ont beaucoup conduit à mon qui sont
pas journalistes, non, qui sont
universitaires [grognement] euh qui ont
beaucoup contribué à mon cheminement
intellectuel et qui n'ont pas réussi à
franchir le mur. Il y a quelque chose
qui s'est qui s'est bloqué chez eux.
Mais ce qui était très intéressant,
c'est que à la demande de Jean-Michel
Ribble, le patron du théâtre du
Rond-point, euh on a procédé à des
lectures avec Arian Ascaride, François
Martouret, Serge Simon qui est devenu le
vice-président de la Fédération
française de rugby mais qui était le
pilier de l'équipe de Bigle qui a été
championne de France en 91 avec qui je
suis copain et moi et on a lu ces
lettres et quand à Ryan Nascarid par
exemple lisait ses lettres, ça a
dégoupillé toute la violence qu'il y
avait dans les lettres. Les gens
rientaient.
Donc voyez qui c'est il y a toujours un
moyen de de d'extirper la violence dans
la tête des hommes et dans la dans dans
les sociétés. Il y a toujours un moyen
de le faire. C'est difficile sans doute.
Ça prend plus de temps qu'on ne le pense
mais il n'y a pas de fatalité à ce que
la violence prime la paix sociale, prime
la concorde.
Inchallah.
Une petite on vous corrige un petit peu.
C'est pas Stéphane Essel, c'est Stéphane
Aurel.
Stéphane Aurel pardon. Oui.
Les gardiens de la raison.
Oui, c'est c'est ce que j'ai dit. C'est
alors pardon, c'est pas Stéphane
Essessel, évidemment, le pauvre paix à
son âme. Non. Euh et c'est et le
troisème il s'appelle Laurence euh je
vais retrouver son nom mais en effet
c'est les gardiens de la raison. C'est
Stéphane Aurel et Stéphane Fouard.
Pardonnez-moi.
Ça fait longtemps qu'on parle.
Oui. On arrive à la fin de notre de
notre interview. Euh euh est-ce que vous
avez trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ?
Oui, oui, oui, j'ai j'ai quelques livres
à leur conseiller.
Alors, je viens de terminer deux livres
qu'il faut il faut lire les deux d'un
auteur américain qui étudie l'histoire
de l'Amérique à travers la question de
la race. Il s'appelle Colson White Head
et [grognement] il a obtenu d'ailleurs
pour ses deux livres le prix Pulitzer.
Le premier s'appelle Underground
Railroad. l'underground Rail, c'était le
nom que l'on donnait à ce à à cette
comment dire à ce réseau de gens,
d'hommes et de femmes qui aidaient des
esclaves qui avaient fui les plantations
à regagner le Canada s'appelait
Underground Railwood et d'ailleurs un
des pères de la désobéissance civile
dans lequel tous les écologistes se
reconnaissent. Henri David Tureau n'a
pas simplement écrit Walden ou la vie
dans les bois. N'a pas simplement écrit
ce petit livre la désobéissance civile
quand il refusait de payer l'impôt qui
finançait l'esclavage et la guerre
contre le Mexique. Mais avec sa mère et
avec sa sœur, il a aidé les les esclaves
euh à Fuyard à regagner le Canada. Il
était donc dans cette Underground
Railroad et Colson White a écrit un
deuxième livre qui a obtenu le prix le
prix Pulzer cette année qui s'appelle
Nickel Boys qui est un livre sur un
centre de de correction entre guillemets
euh qui a existé et dans lequel les
noirs disparaissaient. C'est en même
temps une manière pour Colson White de
regarder l'Amérique à travers cette
question de la race qui est qui est
essentielle. Et là, je suis en train
d'écrire de pas d'écrire de lire un
livre d'Éric Sadin. Éric Sadin, c'est un
philosophe critique qui a écrit
plusieurs livres. Un qui s'appelle la
silicolonisation du monde, un autre qui
s'appelle l'intelligence artificielle ou
l'enjeu du siècle. C'est une référence
directe au livre de Jacquelul, écrit en
1954 qui s'intitulait la technique ou
l'ange du siècle. Et le troisème,
j'arrive plus à me souvenir du titre,
l'individu,
ça finit par ça, l'individu tyront.
l'individu du tyran et c'est l'individu
du tyran et en dessous vous avez dans en
en en
écriture
à la la fin du commun
et donc le livre de Sadin est un livre
est un livre très intéressant et puis
j'ai lu
l'air de l'individu tyran
l'air de l'individu tyran je recommande
vivement et le et puis j'ai lu j'ai lu
un petit livre très sympa qui est un
exercice de style très intéressant de
Laurent Godet qui s'appelle Salina qui
et que je que je vous recommande aussi.
Est-ce que vous avez lu critiques très
virulentes du livre Les gardiens de la
raison ?
Non. Non, ben forcément il y a des il y
aura forcément des critiques virulentes
des gardiens de la raison mais je je
alors là je vais vous dire je suis très
partisan parce que je pense que le
bouquin de de Stéphane Aurel et de
Stéphane Fouard est un est tellement
bien documenté et tellement bien
argumenté que les critiques virulentes
sont des critiques de gens qui sont les
défenseurs de de ce que nous n'aimons
pas. Une dernière question internet de
Tommy.
Monsieur ma mère fait un constat de
choses qui ne vont pas entre parenthèses
A,
exprime aussi un avis sur ce qu'il
faudrait entre parenthèses B. Très bien.
Mais comment passer du A ? Comment être
sûr que l'on ne brasse pas du vent si
l'on ne pense pas de façon réaliste ce
qu'il est nécessaire de faire passer de
faire pour passer de A à B ? Oui, bien
sûr. Mais je sais pas engagez-vous en
politique, hein.
Comment
ne me dites pas engagez-vous en
politique.
Non, j'ai pas dit ça. D'ailleurs, je
pense que voyez si on parle des
prochaines présidentielles par exemple,
c'est illusoire d'imaginer que tous ces
jeunes qui marche pour le climat, tous
ces jeunes qui marchent pour la justice
pour tous, je pense à au collectif Adama
et d'ailleurs c'était très intéressant
de voir devant le tribunal de Paris la
jonction qui s'est faite entre la
justice pour tous du collectif Adama et
ces jeunes, beaucoup de jeunes des
manifes pour le climat, de la justice
pour le climat les ont rejoints et donc
On est maintenant dans une exigence
d'une partie notable de la société d'une
justice pour tous. Cela
c'est pas c'est pas un effet de mode ça.
Non, je pense pas. Non, je pense qu'il y
a une réalité. Quand vous interrogez des
jeunes lycéens qui font les grèves du du
Friday for Climate ou que vous
interrogez de plus des gens plus âgé,
cette génération des 20 ans, ils sont
extrêmement conscients de l'ampleur des
inégalités sociales, extrêmement
conscients de cela et ils lient leur
combat pour le climat la question des
inégalités et ils ont absolument raison.
Mais ces jeunes-là n'adhéreront jamais à
un parti politique. Et donc c'est
illusoire d'imaginer que des alliances
entre parties pourraient suffire à à
faire aimer pardon à faire émerger une
candidature alternative
à Macron. Donc je je pense qu'en effet
on peut très bien considérer comme ce
follower que tout ce qu'on raconte et
l'heure et demi qu'on vient de passer
ensemble ce n'est que du vent. Peut-être
que ce n'est que du vent mais c'est
aussi une contribution. Et puis il y a
pas, j'allais dire pas que des gens
comme moi, on peut pas dire ça parce que
j'ai je suis allé beaucoup sur le
terrain mais il y a tous les jours des
gens qui se battent et les sociétés ne
sont aucune société n'a n'a été
transformée par le haut, c'est par le
bas.
Et donc c'est par la mobilisation. C'est
ce que le le
jeune philosophe Baptiste Morizo, voilà
un livre à lire. Tiens sur la piste
animale. Très bon livre. et son dernier
livre qui est encore plus intéressant
qui s'appelle manière d'être vivant,
manière au pluriel d'être vivant. Et
Baptiste Morizo, il parle de
l'archipélisation des luttes. Voilà, ben
il faut créer un archipel des luttes. Et
des luttes, il y en a, il y en a
beaucoup. Et toute la question de
savoir, c'est en effet si la somme de
ces luttes, ça fera société ou si au
contraire ça restera finalement comme
malheureusement
une manière d'être les idiots utiles
d'un capitalisme qui rebondit et qui est
toujours capable de se de renaître.
Vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations autre que celui-ci ? pour
les jeunes générations, c'est se battre,
se battre et se battre encore parce que
ils savent eux que comme le dit le GC,
nous sommes rentrés dans nous sommes
entrés dans la décennie critique.
Ils sont pas moi ma génération en 68
quand on allait dans les
dans les communautés comme on dit le
retour à la terre, on avait pas ce
sentiment d'urgence.
Ma génération votre époque
c'était la très belle époque. Oui, il y
avait pas le chômage, il y avait pas le
sida, on n pas connu la guerre. Enfin,
on a eu époque bénie. En effet, nous
sommes des privilégiés. Vous êtes
bien gavé, hein.
Comment
vous êtes bien gavé, votre génération ?
Oui, c'est vrai. C'est vrai. On peut le
On peut le dire.
Vous n'avez pas connu la guerre.
C'est ce que je vous dis. On n'a pas
connu la guerre. On n'a pas connu le On
n' pas connu le sida. On n' pas connu le
euh on n' pas connu le le réchauffement,
enfin l'urgence l'urgence climatique.
On n pas connu le chômage. Oui, on a été
en on a connu une époque une époque
bénie en effet. Mais les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui sont parfaitement
conscients de cette urgence et je pense
qu'ils se ils ne verront pas ils ne
resteront pas les bras ballant et donc
c'est à eux que la l'avenir appartient
et si moi je peux faire partie comme
d'autres de ceux qui leur transmettent
qui leur transmettent non pas un certain
nombre de valeurs parce que je n'ai pas
la prétention d'incarner plus de valeurs
que les autres mais un certain nombre
d'outil
mais j'aurais pas servi à rien.
Voilà.
C'est quoi le nom de votre dernière BD
là ?
Alors, le nom de ma dernière BD
s'appelle les terrestres. C'est une
référence directe
euh au livre de Bruno Latour qui est,
pourrait-on dire, le chef de field de ce
qu'on appelle les écophilosophes et son
livre s'appelle Où atterrir avec un
point d'interrogation dans lequel il
explique qu'il ne faudrait plus dire les
terriens parce que les terriens ne
savent pas habiter la terre mais les
terrestres c'estàd comment habiter la
terre autrement. Et donc c'est une série
de reportages dans des écolieux qui
commencent à Notre-Dame des Landes que
je considère comme matriciel. Euh et
puis dans d'autres lieux, c'était cinq
éclairages hein. J'ai fait mon métier de
journaliste en en proposant cinq
éclairages différents dans ces écolieux
qui sont le contraire du survivalisme,
qui sont vraiment branchés sur le tissu
local et les luttes locales même avec
une jeune dessinatrice libanaise de 30
ans qui s'appelle Raphaël Macaron, très
talentueuse
et qui a réussi à traiter un sujet dit
sérieux que l'on croit dont on pense que
la graphie sera austère avec des
couleurs flashies, des couleurs de son
époque de de sa génération et qui a su
surtout très bien mettre en scène ses
interrogations, ses peurs parce qu'en
effet, elle appartient à cette
génération qui lorsqu'on lui parle
d'effondrement ou de chaos,
c'est tellement vertigineux que ça les
branle totalement hein. Et moi je
connais des jeunes qui ont fait des des
petits moments de de dépression face à
ça. Et donc petit à petit, au fur et à
mesure des reportages, grâce au vieil
écolo qui est à côté d'elle,
elle elle prend conscience qu'on n'est
pas en train d'assister à la fin du
monde mais à la fin d'un monde et
comment à partir de ce monde qui est
finissant, comment on construit un autre
?
Noël ma mère, merci.
C'est moi qui vous remercie.
[musique]